Pi,
Tony and cliff.
Hello.
I'm smelling this weed in 12 hours.
I'll be free.
I'm excited for you.
Did.
I didn't do shit for sober October.
You stay drunk.
I didn't stay drunk.
I just had a drink or two pretty much
every night.
Would you ever consider doing something
like sober October?
I mean like if,
you know,
if I was a part of it and like I got all
that promotional push that everybody's
giving themselves.
Hell yeah.
For the business point,
for this.
The only reason why you do it.
That's the only reason I would do it.
I have no reason I'm in.
I'm in,
you know,
I'm in perfect shape.
Feel good about life.
Every day is good.
You know,
I,
I've been cutting back on things
naturally like I'm done with my college
years of,
you know,
getting wasted at the store and things
like that.
It's like when you were also not smoking
cigarettes anymore.
Right?
I'm off cigarettes,
which helps a lot by the way.
You know,
I got to say for anybody out there that
drinks and smokes,
the two correlate,
you quit one.
It's gonna help with the other big tie
split.
I mean I'm just saying like cutting back
on smoking because the two go so good
together.
Yeah.
You were finding that those pens weren't
really helping you that much?
Huh?
The nicotine pendants.
Oh yeah.
No,
I love them.
Yeah.
They're there to help you quit.
You were still,
you were saying that it's not the same.
It's not the same.
I mean when you're a,
when you love cigarettes and both of my
parents smoked.
My mom quit when she got pregnant with
me and then started again like a year
later and she would smoke like in the
little,
you know,
the little house that I grew up in and
it was just always like,
my whole life was,
I was built to be a cigarette smoker.
Those two were probably smoking ciggies
while banging,
making me like,
it was like,
I just love cigarettes.
I even still love the nice gust of
secondhand smoke and now that I'm a
nonsmoker,
it blows my mind.
Hearing people those years say,
oh,
cigarettes stank.
Like,
it's like,
I fucking love it.
Oh,
I just love it.
It just makes me feel good.
It's a weird and I know because it's
pure poison,
it just goes to show like what a dark
Lord I am.
Is that you or is that just cigarettes
in general?
Have a grip on people to dark grip.
It really is so crazy because what else
gives you nothing and takes everything
and still it's just.
This is my favorite part of the day.
Favorite part of the night after sex.
During coffee,
they said that Johnny Carson,
when he was on his deathbed was just
rotting out from the inside.
He was just falling apart and he was
like those goddamn cigarette.
Yeah.
It's one of the main reasons why a,
I actually quit was reading about Johnny
and yeah,
because it's sort of correlated.
I still,
you know,
go on runs every day pretty much every
day,
short jogs and this and that to wake up
and get the day started and there was
awhile there where I was,
had a lot of like confidence,
like coming up.
Not really coughing up shit,
but it was sorta just like it was there
and I'd have to clear my throat before
going on stage and it started to get
like,
it wasn't onstage,
but it started to creep up during work
hours.
Like it's like,
well,
like Joey Diaz just murked a room and
I'm next and he's break you guys ready
for your next to me.
I'm like,
oh,
I gotta get my shit together.
Cough up anything black.
No,
I've,
I've talked to people that have hocked
up shit and it was black and they spit
it on the ground and they saw a black,
like a black luggy yeah.
I was like,
why did you quit immediately?
Like,
no,
six more years.
Yeah.
But I read about Johnny and he was
talking about like,
not only was that a major thing,
like those damn cigarettes,
like that's,
he just kept repeating that on his
deathbed,
but they also talk about like how he was
like swimming,
which he loved to do and he just
couldn't do it anymore.
So it was like almost drowning all the
time and stuff.
Like it was just like he was out,
he was gone.
He just couldn't breathe.
That guy went through a rough patch.
Like not just that.
Do you ever read the divorce settlements
that Johnny Carson had to go through
now?
He was one of the most famous like
divorce rapings where you just go,
oh my God.
Like you find out how much he had to pay
his ex wife.
Like,
oh,
Jesus.
No,
he,
he got taken.
Oh Man.
Murphy had a bit about it.
Eddie Murphy had a bit about Johnny
Carson's divorce in his act.
I think it was in Ra did it on one of
his specials?
Yes.
Wow.
It was that bad gi on the national
enquirer,
but it says 220 grand a month was not
enough.
Wow.
Carson's wife rejects settlement and
asks $220,000
a month and living expenses.
17 million is not enough.
She said that's still.
What year does that say at the top left?
80.
80 three or [inaudible] 93.
What did she look like?
She looks Kinda hot.
They're not like that dirty 40 that
dirty 40 year old.
Look,
I like that.
Good.
Back then.
That's like a million a month closing on
her.
That was the one he split up with.
He.
He gives up fast life and is secretly
seeing wife again.
Oh,
well that's the inquirer.
You know what I mean?
That's what I was getting.
So that's,
that's the Gal who was married to that.
He had to give up 17 million bucks.
Oh.
So he's married to her for a long time.
Well,
how many times did he get married?
That seems like the same gal there.
World's most expensive.
World's most expensive divorce
settlements.
Johnny Carson and Joanna Holland.
20 million.
That ain't shit now.
We were going over some last night or
yesterday on the podcast a Steve Wynn
gave up a billion.
Oh.
What could she have possibly have done
to earn that?
Nothing.
There's nothing she could have done.
She had the Voodoo postseason unless she
had all the ideas and he's just not
admitting it unless she started casino
casino.
You should have craft crafts
table even then.
Even then,
how much is a consultation fee worth?
A billion.
Oh wait.
Yeah.
Well,
that miss sort of looked at him,
by the way.
He looks like he's wearing a mask.
He looks like it's 24 slash seven.
Yeah.
Third divorce.
Unlikely for Steve Wynn.
Wow.
Poor guy.
Good Lord.
You think guys just keep going in.
That's what's crazy.
They're like,
no,
no.
She's the one.
Oh No,
no.
It's never going to change.
Yeah,
he's got it all figured out.
No,
no,
she's the one.
Oh yeah.
It's a strange thing.
You know,
it becomes,
it comes humorous like Elizabeth Taylor,
who was stunningly beautiful when she
was young.
Did you ever see who's afraid of
Virginia Wolf [inaudible]?
It's a must.
See,
it's a great,
great old movie.
But uh,
Elizabeth Taylor was probably in her
twenties I guess when she did that and
she was just so beautiful.
But as she got older,
like shoes,
see if he could see that.
That's a pretty good picture of her.
But if you see like her whole body and
everything,
I mean she was just a bombshell and she
was a bombshell and you know,
what was it?
The fifties or something like that.
Like that picture of her black and white
on the second level where you see your
body.
Yeah.
That's a real body to dude.
Ain't no gym time there.
That's just straight up genetics and
whiskey.
Look at them going on legs and 10 high.
That's just just as biology.
But then towards the end,
I mean she had been married and
divorced.
Don't show the old pictures.
You stop at Jamie.
Google.
Uh,
Elizabeth Taylor.
Amount of times married because uh,
I believe she was married.
Uh,
yeah I want to say like seven or eight
times.
No fewer than eight times.
Yeah.
Married a couple of guys twice.
Eight marriage is only seven husbands.
She married Richard Burton twice.
She married a bunch of gay guys too.
Huh?
Allegedly gay guys.
Her first marriage.
One of the heirs of the hotelier.
That's a weird word.
Hotelier.
Hotel.
He airs.
Said Conrad Hilton and didn't divorce
after less than a year.
Yeah.
She was a wild woman.
Wild.
She got paid for all this.
That's it's own business,
right?
With rich as fuck.
You know,
she was really successful as an actress.
So she probably had the money and a lot
of them because she was dating some guys
that looked suspiciously homosexual,
you know,
like liberace,
homosexual,
like wait what?
Like,
yeah,
hit a million dollars to play Cleopatra
in 1963.
Yeah.
A million bucks in 1963.
He's probably like 20 million bucks a
day.
What does it mean?
Google that.
What is a million dollars in 1963 worth
today?
That's crazy.
They paid her that much money.
Damn.
Who?
Whoever her agent is,
dig that motherfucker up this dollar
times.com
says it's worth a point.
One billion eight.
Yeah,
that's it.
So yeah.
Wow.
I thought it wouldn't be like 20 annual
inflation over this period was three
point eight.
Eight percent.
That's um,
and when you think of like,
like who's the top paid female today?
Is it Jennifer Lawrence?
Maybe?
Probably.
Yeah.
What does she get?
She probably gets like 20,
right?
Somewhere in that 15 to 20 range
probably.
Yeah.
So she shits on Elizabeth Taylor
[inaudible] fucking hunger games pitch.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
But anyway,
um,
she married a bunch of gay guys I think.
See if you find out Elizabeth Taylor
married gay guys,
because that was like always the standup
comedy joke that,
uh,
when I was first starting out,
I remember a bunch of guys had jokes
about Elizabeth Taylor and merge chick
had a joke about it too.
But Elizabeth Taylor always married gay
guys,
like not knowing like she's so old and
fucked up on pills.
She doesn't know the guy she's married
or gay.
That's crazy.
I wonder why she would do that.
That was probably one companionship.
You know,
she was,
I think in the end there was a rumors of
substance abuse.
I mean,
I,
I'm,
I'm prolife perilla proliferate per
peripherally,
peripherally associated with these new
stores.
I don't really know him that well.
You know,
I just remember reading something about
substance abuse and drinking and yeah.
Then there's always rough man ends rough
for a lot of people,
bro.
Yeah.
There's those pain pills and everything.
Kitchen.
The roughest of the rough man.
People who go out with those pain pill
addictions we think about.
We were talking about a Joey Diaz and I
were talking yesterday about Prince.
Um,
you know,
he was,
uh,
he called me up and he was singing to
me.
He was singing that song.
Do you bought him a do he won't be Jew.
He's like Purple Brain Cock sucker.
Joe Rogan.
What was the last time you listened to
purple rain?
He goes,
I'm stone as a motherfucker right now
listening to purple rain.
God Damn prints was good.
And I was thinking about it like prince
was just one of the many greats that we
lost a pain pills just real recently.
Tom Petit Prince.
Who else?
We will last several,
several big name,
powerful celebrities to pain pills.
Michael Jackson now he was propafol.
He was um,
he was in pain pills.
He was that shit that they use to put
people under.
Yeah.
But he was in like a lot of pain,
right?
Wasn't that one of his things?
I think so.
I think he was just so fucked up in the
head.
So he had so much anxiety and he,
uh,
he just,
he couldn't sleep.
It was just a mess,
man.
Huh?
What those rumors have that he was
addicted to pain pills.
Michael Jackson.
Yeah.
Shit did.
Yeah,
and he was,
he was working to make that big comeback
thing at the time too.
So they had him out there dancing and
shit.
Looking like a bag of bones.
Yeah,
pretty sure.
They said that the pro pro pro fall is
what killed him because he couldn't
sleep also.
Yeah.
You need to sleep.
And what that,
what he was doing is just getting
sedated every night.
I mean that's the reason why as Dr went
to jail.
He called it milk,
right?
Playing smaller than milk.
Oh God.
Can I have,
I'm having a little trouble keeping the.
Oh,
it sparked from that accident he got in
when he got on fire.
Oh,
that's right.
He caught his hair on fire for the pain
from that.
Yeah.
Well that's,
that's what happened to this guy that I
know.
He,
he hurt himself doing construction and
then gone on some pills,
you know,
because he had a back injury and they
put them on pills and then life is over.
It takes us one accident.
I've only taken a half of one pain pill
one time and I know the exact day that
it happened because it was the day that
the wwe network came out.
I had my wisdom teeth pulled and they're
like,
take,
take all of these that you want.
I'm like,
ah,
I don't really,
uh,
you know,
I'm very reactive to pills,
blah,
blah.
But I saw,
but I was in a lot of pain,
so I'm like,
fuck it.
I'll take a half of one and man,
if I didn't go through that whole
network's library that day,
just with a smile on my face and
drooling on myself,
loving life,
just watching all the old stuff that I
watched as a kid.
Wow.
So fun.
Let's see.
It was the day the network came out.
It would be nice if pain pills didn't do
anything bad to you.
They just fucked you up.
But no physical harm,
no addiction.
That would be part.
No addiction,
no physical harm.
I mean,
people are always going to be.
People are addicted to washing their
hands.
I mean,
people are addicted to really weird
shit,
but there's always going to be people
that are addicted to things in that they
can't quit doing them,
but addiction,
like in your bones,
those pain pills.
So they,
they feel.
It felt so good.
I remember the feeling of just like,
oh,
this is the greatest feeling that I
could do this all the time.
This is incredible.
It's just such a,
it's in comparable to even like,
you know,
drink or pot or anything like that.
It's just sit there and smile.
Just waves of heat
real sick once and I got ahold of that
real nyquil in the nineties was the last
time I took it.
The real Nyquil,
that stuff.
I guess it was coding.
Was it coding that was in there?
Yeah,
something like that.
Right.
It's the CICERO.
It was wonderful.
I was just,
I was just the my pillow and my blanket
would just cuddling me with love and I
was just lying in bed with a stupid
smile on my face watching TV,
just like,
uh,
I'm so happy.
Yeah.
They don't make that Nyquil like they
used to.
You got to get it from a doctor.
Shady dot ephedrine is what it was
called.
That's what it is.
Yeah.
Nasal congestion,
I think.
I mean says what was taken out of it.
So why don't I think it is it.
Light coating is a coating.
We've done this before,
right?
We talked about this before.
I saw there's a thc liquid,
something other being sold in 1200
milligram,
but it's sold in like a bottle that
looks just like the.
Somebody tried to visit or something.
Somebody tried to give me some
marijuana.
Beer.
Yeah.
THC infused beer.
Like you get that shit the fuck away
from me.
They're making cbd infused beer soon.
Like I think budweiser,
coors or budweiser.
Someone invested a Shitload of money
into in Canada or mgd.
Wow.
That's interesting.
Well,
it would counteract the effects of
alcohol and somewhat because one of the
things about alcohol right,
is that it causes inflammation.
CBD perhaps could counteract the
inflammation.
Yeah.
Putting my scientist,
I don't mess around with
any of that.
THC infused stuff.
I liked it.
I liked the CBD.
THC,
when it comes to anything other than
smoking it,
I do not play.
No.
What I like pal,
I like these joints that are wrapped in
tobacco.
These backwoods,
Jeremy's.
These are my favorite because they give
you like a little bit of elevation.
You get a little bit from the,
from the cigarette,
the nicotine that tobacco,
and then you get the weed.
Whoa.
Combo Corona and Modelo Corona.
Modelo was the first to take the plunge.
Investing hundreds of millions of
dollars into a Canadian outfit,
nor to bring thc infused bruise to
market in northern nation.
Now molson coors,
the second largest brewer in the world
is reportedly getting into the game.
The game.
Yeah.
That's what's going to be interesting is
when like smirnoff starts investing in
marijuana because they're going to.
It's a hundred percent legal in Canada
now.
Canada is just.
It's just like buying a beer.
It's thank God Canada.
Any bad motherfuckers up there
and you can travel in Canada and fly
with it.
Yeah.
Well I love you could fly into lax with
wheat now.
Heck yeah.
Yeah.
They say whatever happens when you get
there as on you,
right?
Yeah.
Did you see the thing that they have in
Vegas?
They have dispensary like or dispensers
for marijuana like at the airport and
then people were breaking into them and
they're stealing weed out of them.
Keeping that we.
And they said they're not free weed
boxes.
You assholes.
Was it crossing international borders
with cannabis is illegal.
It's at the airport there.
Yeah.
But does that mean going back or
landing?
You can bring it in or take it out,
but just saying like if you're at the
airport,
just make sure you're standing here.
Isn't that interesting?
Like you can't even bring it in even
though it's legal there.
Yeah,
it's weird.
There's the box.
Yeah.
There's the box disposal for
prescription and recreational drug.
Is that in Canada?
One's in Canada,
but yet they haven't been denver.
Also.
I have the exact.
I have photo.
The exact same thing from Vegas.
I took a picture of a company that's
supposed to come around and pick the
shit up and for those of it you get you
a little skinny arms in there.
Oh
God,
that is so funny.
It's a disposal all the times.
That last second.
I'm just throwing joint tubes into the.
Into the,
into the trashcan.
Like who would actually go up to that
thing and throw it in there?
No one.
Let me.
Let me tell you.
Yeah,
super fucked up.
Pot.
Old Toronto area cannabis.
Anna's amnesty cans.
That's hilarious.
This is just some guy laying on the
ground with his mouth open and the
bottom of that.
Tell me a story about a girl who was a.
She went into a Porta potty and she.
She thought she saw something like when
she's sitting down and then she realized
she heard like groans.
She realized there was some guy in there
inside the Porta Potty,
just laying there,
watching the shit come out and hitting
him in the head with his mouth open
while she's shitting and pissing on him.
Oh my God.
Climbed in to this shit and Piss.
That is so disgusting and hot at the
same time.
For some reason,
the fact that a monster would lay there
like that,
he's probably got a fucking snorkel,
a Porta potty.
Pieper Luke Christo Suing Boulder for
$99,999
or equal amount of gold coinage from
Boulder,
Colorado.
He's suing boulder or so.
It happened in.
In Boulder.
Yeah.
Boulder's attribute placement.
People been getting really high in
boulder for a long time and there's no
air up there.
So if you get super baked in boulder,
like you could blow a fuse.
Look at that potty.
It's like built for that.
It looks like it's like a float tank
top.
It's like a little.
You know what it's like.
It's like one of those first class seats
you get when you fly to Australia.
Oh yeah.
Little pod.
A pod.
It says what's just getting weird?
I don't know.
Oh,
hold on.
Chris Ko has made his mark on the
internet under a variety of monikers,
including Omni Rainbow and Sky Oregon
who youtube channel features,
clips,
including this one in which he
demonstrates his thigh rubbing
technique.
Videos,
not there for some reason.
Yeah.
I wonder why it's been pulled from the
Internet.
So this is the guy.
So he was.
He climbed in there to have people shit
on him.
And how did he know that there was a
girl?
His reward for such patients was a site
of a slender,
black haired white man.
What?
Wait a minute.
Don't scroll.
What are you going to know?
What the hell they're talking about?
But I'm reading that grow back a slender
sweat,
black haired white man standing between
six point five and six foot eight inches
tall with cuts on his back and arms
wearing only a pair of sweatpants.
What is this about?
Oh,
so this is the security guard realized
that he was doing something.
Scroll back up to that.
Figure out what the other one.
Imagine like waiting there under the
toilet in the Porta potty for a hot
chick to come in.
And just like Joey Diaz comes in like
I'm excited.
Sandwiches all week.
June 2011.
We noted that a woman attended the
Hammond Festival,
stepped into a portable laboratory in
which he lifted totes lid.
She saw something moving in the deep
dark depths below q shock,
horror and quick escape.
Was She fetched a man and asked him to
look inside?
He too saw some movement beneath a tarp
inside the tank,
and after exiting the chamber,
he heard the door locked behind them.
At that point he summoned his security.
Okay.
That's what happened.
And then they caught that guy.
So he's in there with a tarp hiding
under a tarp.
While people were shitting on him.
Look at his face.
Is that the mugshot?
Is their shit all over him?
Oh God.
Son of a bitch.
It's like the clown meets the shit
clown.
Oh,
look at this.
He sat down with Fox 31 for a jailhouse
interview in which you referred to
spying on urinating or defecating.
Women in quotes,
the highest creature in the universe.
He maintained as in quotes,
praising God and said in quotes,
it sounds kind of weird,
but I would just find my peace and go
away.
Say thank you goddess and go about my
night.
Wow.
Isn't that the scariest part?
When you.
When you drop a deuce on the toilet and
you hear the words,
thank you.
God is coming from the toilet.
You got us through your offerings just
to other peoples and other places around
boulder.
Also just serve restaurants.
Just to know that
someone like that as a real person like
do you have to realize sometimes you
have to see someone like that to go,
oh,
okay.
I don't know everybody.
There's,
there's a,
there's a
long
range,
you know,
if there's a chart of like fucked up to
like totally normal.
There's a lot of variables in there and
there's a lot of people that just don't
fit into your ideal.
Who knows?
We may know people that are into that
type of thing.
We should set up like a tractor.
Skakel what?
What'd you say?
No,
I said we might know people.
Would you say earl?
Jeff.
Ross.
You say Jeff Ross,
you son of a bitch.
You should put.
Listen in.
Don't do that off camera and expect me
to keep secrets.
We should put one of those watkins.
Just kidding folks.
Just we like,
we love those guys.
Just jokes.
Oh yeah.
Do you think we do anything?
We know.
Anybody looks at your shit on Jim
Norton.
Yeah,
maybe.
No worries.
It'll tell you we should put one behind
the comedy store and see if anyone
starts to like look it up and down and
lay down in it.
You know,
they had this test they did with,
uh,
with men where they took men that were.
Now before we get any further,
I don't know who conducted these tests.
Jamie could probably find it.
Well,
they,
um,
they conducted
tests where they put devices on penises
who talked about this was Christopher
Ryan may have talked about this and
maybe our friend Chris Ryan talked about
this.
They put sensors on penises and they
showed homophobic men,
erotica and homosexual erotica in
particular,
like guys getting their Dick sucked by
guys and they got aroused by it.
They put these things on it.
So that's what we would need to do.
We need to like,
ah,
that'd be phobic.
Men are aroused by gay male porn.
Here it is.
Homophobia is associated with sexual
excitement by male on male sex.
That's one study.
This is the greatest reality show ever
in the making right now.
All right.
One study asked heterosexual men how
comfortable and anxious they are around
gay men based on these scores,
they then divided these into two groups,
men that are homophobic,
amended or not.
These men were then shown three,
four minute videos.
That's a long time.
You're sitting there watching to dude
suck a dick.
One video depicted straight sex,
one,
two,
big depicted lesbian sex and one
depicted gay male sex.
While this was happening,
a device that was attached to each
participant's penis.
This device has been found to be
triggered by sexual arousal,
but not by other types of arousal,
such as nervousness or fear.
Arousal often has a very different
meaning in psychology.
Then improper usage.
Hmm.
Wonder what the device looks like.
It's just some dude's mouth to mouth.
Pretty sure this was a Japanese game
show.
Experimental was they had a guy get
blown by another dude and he had to last
a certain amount of time.
Oh,
I did hear that.
Kept them under a weight.
He had the last without coming.
He had to go four or five minutes or
something without blowing a little kid
when a bunch of money
and if a guy was sucking his dick is
people don't realize that Japanese
before fear factor Japanese game shows
were on another level.
They were doing some fucking insane shit
on Japanese TV.
That was one of the.
Some of the early youtube clips we used
to watch was Japanese game shows.
Those guys are way.
They're always ahead of it.
Ninja warrior.
Yeah.
Right.
Was that a Japanese show first?
I think so.
Yeah.
Should be when it first started,
like that's how it got onto the way it
is because g four had a contest for like
the first American to go over and do it
and it just sort of snowballed from
there
and then they had that show that was
kind of a version of it for America
called wipe out.
Right.
Remember that because that was the same
people that produced fear factor
produced,
wipe out
MFC where they would like auto dm or did
the voice dubs and it would seem a
little funny,
but they'd be like the waiters,
the service staff,
and it'd be almost a big joke.
Remember I'm talking about.
No,
it was called Mx.
see like I don't remember the full name.
I'll pull up a video and see.
So anyway,
we put these sensors on Earl's kcals
Dick and have someone take a shit in
front of.
I was like,
what the fuck?
What am I doing guys?
Nothing,
girl.
We're sorry.
We're just joking around.
Oh,
that girl got hit in the head kick.
Now here's the thing,
I can't help but thinking that ladies
running through shit now after we talked
about,
I don't think I don't see that as mud.
It's just a silly Japanese show.
But here's the uh,
the other one I was telling you about,
this is the only,
I can only find it on live leak,
but it is a gay versus straight blow job
challenge.
Oh my God.
So who's the Gay Guy?
This big guy,
I believe the big guy's gay and the
straight guy.
Wow.
This gay guy says those pants are hot,
and so this guy has to stand there,
see if we can get Takuya.
Oh my God.
Of course,
if he doesn't get hard,
see,
he might not get hard like this.
What does the expression mean?
Oh my God,
welcome to another episode of high speed
vacuum.
Puts his hand in his mouth.
His expression has changed dramatically.
Like,
wow,
it's always those fat guys that really
sucked the best dicks.
I bet.
I love that.
At the end of that comment,
I don't have to say.
I bet I would imagine because it's like
a comment.
This guy took his shirt off.
What happened there?
Shot.
Thank you.
I enjoyed that.
He says,
oh my God,
so that poor guy.
We have a winner.
Oh,
that poor guy.
Just not in that dude's mouth.
He says,
that's frustrating.
A lot came out,
didn't it?
He says,
it's so frustrating.
No.
Yeah,
but a lot came out.
Tell them.
The guy's like,
dude,
you enjoyed that.
You came really hard.
He was.
It was very frustrating because like,
yeah,
but a lot came out.
You came hard,
Yay.
But frustrating,
dumb like no,
but you liked it at the time because a
lot came out.
I can only comes out if it feels good.
That is there evil that's fucking with
the person's mind.
You know,
you guys to think about that shit for
the rest of his life.
He's probably gay now.
He's probably on the other side of the
game show second.
The reason why I would imagine fat guys
suck Dick Betters because it involves
food and and gay sex at the same time.
It's a combination of things like fat
people probably like things in their
mouth.
And then on top of that,
gay sex and Asian as well.
Kobiashi is the hot dog eating champion.
I thought you were going to go with a
little Dick.
Uh,
we'll get the whole thing that you're
not choking.
You could promote it.
You can really go to town and it might
not even make it to your throat.
Just deep now flip it.
I don't know,
that's a terrible stereotype,
but I'm really embarrassed you brought
that up on the show.
Yeah.
How dare you.
Indeed,
and if anybody knows things about
stereotypes,
it's Asians and Megan Kelly.
That was an Asian Stereo.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
okay.
I get it.
Like Samsung.
Yeah,
exactly.
I get it.
Yeah.
Megan Kelly.
That's a crazy one.
That's a crazy one because she said dad
did.
I never really got it all the way.
She said that back in her day,
people used to be black for Halloween.
She said,
why can't you dress up as like Diana
Ross?
Yeah.
I guess she essentially said,
what's wrong with wearing blackface?
She's like,
why is it bad for she?
She threw one in.
That's not even really bad as it like.
She started with,
why is it bad for a black person to
dress up as a white person or white
person dress up as a black person?
Well,
it's not.
Nobody says it's bad for a black person
who dressed up as a white person.
Dave Chappelle did it on his TV show
forever.
Remember that we do that.
Nobody cared.
It's bad because these two have minstrel
shows,
like if she knew the history of it,
like you go to back and watch Al Jolson.
Have you ever watched some of that
stuff?
A little bit,
but I mean we should watch some of that.
Okay.
The Al Jolson stuff.
Really what would happen?
We go to jail.
Just pc police,
youtube.
What about white chicks?
Remember white chicks when the Wayans
brothers.
Uh Oh yeah.
They hit that whole movie where there
were white face.
Huge movie.
Nobody cares.
Heavily promoted movie.
Funny movie.
Yeah,
you could.
You could be white.
Nobody cares.
So her saying that was very
disingenuous.
It was just to cover our ass.
So that's Al Jolson.
So what does the jazz singer.
Al Jolson.
Yeah.
And look at what he used to do with his
lips.
He used to make his lips cartoonishly
exaggerated any would sing,
but he was like an obviously a white man
singing in black face as a black man.
It's,
it's really weird to watch.
And he would wear white gloves on,
is it wrong that I feel weird or
watching this.
Then reading about the guy that was
getting shit and pissed on,
is it wrong that you came quicker than
the guy?
Man,
man,
that's crazy.
Pretty sure.
That was the first movie with sound also
was the first movie was sound,
was racist as fuck.
When you got to realize the first movie
was sound.
Was that probably 19 one slash seven
slash 27.
Okay.
So that is,
what is that 60 years after slavery?
That's after it was abolished,
but it wasn't even really done when it
was abolished.
So yeah.
But when was it done?
Okay.
Arguably it isn't with jails,
but I mean there was still Jesus teach
Jamie with deep were still.
They weren't all slaves weren't
immediately twitter.
You got to them like
slaves weren't immediately released and
when the law passed didn't just say
you're free because that's a good point.
But what I meant was when I just like,
I don't know,
I don't know the date you're looking for
like it happened gradually over time.
So yeah,
because of civil war,
civil war ended in 18,
$75.
I wouldn't have did it ended at 65.
But the resolution to abolish slavery
was passed proclamation that was 65,
64,
and then the civil war ended just a
couple years later.
Right.
Space Proclamation,
January first 18,
63,
and then the war ended 1865.
So that's not that long.
Like 60 years later they're doing.
You ever heard it?
It's so weird.
It's,
it's weird watching old movies.
Period.
Yeah,
they'd go like the 19 twenties and shit.
It's like it's.
So I,
I,
I've watched King Kong with my kids.
I had them watch the original King Kong
and there were we going to be scared.
This was a few years back,
like when one was six and one was for,
look,
we're nervous.
Worse.
Can I go?
Don't be scared to.
It's not scary.
Just trust me.
You're gonna think it's funny.
They were laughing.
They thought it was so funny.
It looks so bad.
It looks so Corny,
right?
We're just cuddled up on the couch
watching King Kong looks so corny.
Like the claymation or law.
It's just weird that back then that was
a horror movie.
Like people would go to the movie like
that was terrifying.
Yes,
it was.
I'm going to go get a sandwich.
My goodness.
I'm going to order coffee for a penny.
I saw the new Halloween movie the other
day that it was awesome.
They actually did it.
They made a great movie.
Great reboot.
It was really awesome.
If you've ever enjoyed any moment or
know anything about Michael Myers at
all,
it's unbelievable.
Wow.
Really Great.
It's like modern day.
They make Jamie Lee curtis a bad ass.
Like she's like,
she's her age.
It's bothered her her whole life.
Every.
All anyone wants to talk with her about
is that.
So she like lifted weights and shit.
She holds,
she holds herself up and this big.
She builds a compound with fences and
everything in case he ever fucking comes
back and she teaches herself how to
shoot.
Like it's like real awesome dude.
You fucking love it.
I couldn't believe it the rest of the
night.
I was saying that my wife just just,
I can't believe how great that movie was
and she loved it too.
So it's like all around wow.
Honest,
rotten tomato say about it.
Those people are crazy.
I don't listen to any but any of these
people's opinions.
I went to a yelp review the other day
because,
uh,
there's this restaurant that I really
liked this near my house and I said,
I wonder how it gets reviewed on Yelp.
And it was like all five stars except
one,
one star,
and it was like a crazy review or some
woman was,
she was yelling,
she was complaining.
That tips that if you tip on a credit
card that they don't get it until the
end of the week and then it gets taxed.
Like,
is that how it always works or do you
get it at night?
They cash you out?
It depends on the restaurant.
It depends on the restaurant,
but I felt like that was probably common
that some restaurants will give you with
your weekly check all your tips for
that.
Typical.
Yeah,
that would be if like they're pulling
perhaps all the tips of the week
together and splitting it amongst
everybody,
which only a really,
really,
really good restaurant with deal.
Oh,
that seems.
That seems like it doesn't encourage
performance though,
right?
Well that at that level of restaurants,
the performances,
like a given,
like they're probably splitting vast
sums of money because it's a full blown
machine,
like a five star.
Exactly.
I worked at Ruth's Chris Steakhouse
coming out of high school and I learned
pretty much everything there is to know
that they make you memorize a stack of
cards.
You have to know everything and the
whole thing's a well oiled machine.
I was a food runner,
which basically means that I had to make
sure that everything going to the tables
was perfectly set up.
Like [inaudible].
There's no fixing it once it leaves the
door.
Right.
So you're basically the final approver
of everything and the servers just
waiting at the table or follows behind
you.
You set the tray down and they do it and
you get 10 percent of all the servers
tips on the floor.
So sometimes some nights if there's,
you know,
uh,
say more than 10 to one food runner or a
servers to food runners,
you could make more than even a server
at a ruth's Chris Steakhouse.
But each restaurant does it differently
and splits tips.
Maybe they pull them that night.
Pulling the tips actually usually means
that the service is going to be
unbelievable.
Unless it's just a Janky restaurant.
Then they then they probably just do it
normally.
Well this restaurant's very nice
restaurant.
Yeah.
So anyway,
I looked at this lady's a one star
review,
like one star to five stars and I always
have a big smile on my face when I see a
one star review because that means this
bitch going to have a lot of one star
reviews.
If you go to her page to page,
it was all one star reviews.
This fucking malcontent,
this monster.
It was just going everywhere and
complaining about everything from
fucking nail salons to movie theaters.
Like everything.
It's crazy.
I don't think trolls and know that
anybody is just one click away from
knowing from them being completely
exposed.
I think it's the same thing,
you know,
on twitter or really anything,
right?
You see someone say something crazy,
you just click on their profile and it's
all crazy.
All crazy all the time to everybody.
Yeah.
They're complaining about everything.
I think
after Roseanne was on,
I got a bunch of people that tweeted at
me with these wacky conspiracies like
wacky mind control conspiracies and what
would it seemed to me to be.
I'm not a professional,
but if I had
to guess a wave of mentally ill people
were contacting me and I was,
I was reading this.
I'm like,
Jesus Christ.
How many people are out there that
believe like the most nuttiest,
CIA based mind control experiments and
NSA,
you know,
tapping into everything in your home and
listening to your conversations by
listening to the vibrations off of your
window panes,
like,
here's what people don't know.
Who's got time for that?
Here's the thing.
Do you really think there's enough
people in the world to be paying
attention to all the people in the
world?
Does that make any sense to you?
It shouldn't.
There's no way.
Everybody's watching everybody.
There's not enough people.
See like if you do something like say
Tony Hinchcliffe runs for President,
oh,
they're going to fucking watch you.
For sure.
They're going to find out what?
Why is Tony Hinchcliffe friend for
president who's backing him?
Is it George Soros who's looking out for
Tony Hinchcliffe?
You know who's trying,
who's fourth?
Yeah,
they'll check you out,
but the average person is like,
remembered that Mel Gibson movie
conspiracy theory,
remember that he played a mentally ill
person who fell in love with Julia
Roberts.
He was like a hot mentally ill person
and uh,
he just believed everything was a
conspiracy theory.
I'm watching the other day,
like out of nowhere,
it was on tv and I saw watched us for a
little bit and I was like,
wow,
fucking wacky.
This movie,
people that have schizophrenia don't
realize that their schizophrenia,
exact people with bipolar notice,
they might be aware that they're having
an episode.
People OCD,
they're ocd add add schizophrenia.
It's game set.
Match.
You start hearing the voices become a
normal thing.
Like you think everybody can hear them
and you're not really acknowledging them
because they become so natural.
The schizophrenia person can be in a
psych ward and say to their doctor,
why am I here?
And that's a breakthrough.
Yeah.
Do you know Matt Mark Marin?
Heard voices in his head for over a
year.
Oh my goodness.
After partying with kinison.
Wow.
That's a hard Kennison.
Pardon?
Yeah.
Were pussies,
man.
We really are.
I was talking to artist the other day at
the back door and it's just like,
my God,
I literally said the words.
I'm like,
I wish I was.
I wish I had started back when you
started,
man.
Really?
Because he was talking about.
We ended up getting off on this whole.
I don't know how we got there,
but we started off on this whole tangent
about,
uh,
about just,
you know,
sobriety and stuff.
And he's like,
man,
you know,
back in my day.
And he was,
I can't remember the exact dialogue,
but it was just.
Yeah,
I mean those guys were all.
It was all just a blur.
I learned something from Argus.
Argus runs like insane numbers of miles
every day,
like 12 miles,
15 miles a day.
The addict in him,
the guy that loved getting wasted,
that's his high now.
He talks about it all the time is
runner's high.
It's real good.
It's real.
I know now because of this month,
this month is sober.
October month,
dude,
I've worked out no less than at least
two hours.
That's a small workout,
a small workout with.
That's all I could get in was two hours
the longest I did.
I did six hours one day.
Good Lord.
Six hours of insane cardio.
It's like both kill bills.
I did seven.
I did seven hours of cardio in the last
two days between yesterday and the day
before.
Seven hours of hard cardio,
different stuff,
running the hills with the dog
elliptical machine or meeting with fat
people.
Right now I'm competing with myself.
First of all,
my main competition is already should
fear and whether you realize it or not
are should fear,
even though he doesn't exercise.
Ari has a strong mind.
He's a very strong mind.
Already ran 15 miles the other day.
Fifteen miles.
He rode five kilometers and then after
he wrote five kilometers,
he um,
he did something else.
He rode his bike.
He rode a bike for a certain amount of
miles,
15 miles.
The whole thing.
His whole workout was,
I think four hours.
My goodness.
He's got that power Giugiaro.
He's got that escape from concentration
camp.
Gene Dude,
he's,
you saw a fucking heart.
He was going on the rowing machine.
He goes hard dude.
He stayed in the 80 percent on the
rowing machine for an hour.
I mean he really did.
I saw him.
I was out there with them.
I filmed it.
I put it up on instagram at that point
when burt was making fun of him for
being at 75 for just walking.
Isn't that him being out of shape?
It's not because when Burton him went
walking,
he was in way better shape than bird see
our.
He rides his bike in New York and he
walks a lot in New York and even though
he's not in great shape,
like in terms of like a guy who runs in
comparison to Bert,
he's in fantastic shape.
When they went hiking together,
bird had a stop like a bunch of times,
but we were still up and I was pissed
off.
He's like,
why do I have to stop?
Because you're fat.
Like.
Yeah.
So like he wanted to see what would
happen if the two of them went out
together and did the exact same hiking,
who's,
because Bert was saying,
oh,
it's because you're not insured,
so your heart is always at 80 percent.
No red in a week is in way better shape
that bird is in this whole life of
working out and drinking vodka every
night compared to bird.
But compared to burt.
But my point is he was my real
competition.
I was very,
very much worried about him.
So up until,
uh,
two days ago,
everything seemed to be going good.
I was working out really hard and uh,
I was,
it was hard.
It's hard to do three hours a day.
It's three and a half hours a day.
Two days in a row is three and a half
hours a day.
Um,
but I started paying and he started
coming out dark.
Oh No,
like iced tea.
Oh Shit.
This sounds like a guy at a Porta
potties.
Dream.
Sweet tea.
What is it?
What does he say at the end?
Oh bless you.
God bless you.
Got It.
For your sweet tea,
I was famished.
Yeah.
It didn't look good today.
I had to go to something in my kid's
school list,
some Halloween thing and I had to go up
three flights of stairs,
free long flights of stairs.
I got to talk.
First of all,
I barely made it upstairs.
I got to the top.
I was out of breath.
My legs were shaking.
Whoa.
Three flights of stairs.
And I was like,
okay,
I might have fucked up.
Oh man,
that was today.
Today.
What does it mean?
Um,
I think my body's breaking down.
I think I've got like serious muscle
breakdown to the point.
Like my muscles are so sore that I,
I've,
I'm ignoring that they're sore and even
though they're really,
really sore,
I'm still doing like three hours of
cardio.
Like I limped up to the,
uh,
to the trail when I ran with my dog
yesterday.
And then I ran two miles and then after
I ran two miles,
I did an hour and a half on the
elliptical machine.
And then after I did an hour and a half
on the elliptical machine,
I did 45 minutes of kicking the bag,
punching and kicking me.
I took two naps yesterday,
two separate maps.
My point is argus taught me something by
telling me about this high that you get
from all this cardio and also kind of
fucking nonsense that I knew that there
was like an endorphin high,
but I didn't.
I didn't think it was a really specific.
But there's a very specific high that
you get and it's like if you could take
a pill that puts you in the state of
mind that I am when I work out this
much,
everybody would take it in the world
would be a better place because you
don't give a fuck,
right?
You don't give a fuck about anything.
I mean not they don't care about people
and friends and loved ones,
but there's no.
Anxiety is no.
All the chatter,
all the negative chatter that you get,
any brand that you have to like push off
and ignore,
let's shuts off.
Right.
Gone.
Nonexistent.
And I wonder how much of that is there
because your brain is almost trying to
create problems and conflict because
you're not getting enough exercise
because your body supposed to get a
specific amount of exercise.
My dog is a,
I think like eight months old or
something now and I've learned a lot
from having this dog this time.
Like I didn't notice a lot of stuff with
the other dogs that I've raised in the
past because in the past,
because with this one it's very clear
and I mean they're all that way,
but if you don't work it out you don't
take it and exercise it.
She's crazy.
She,
she can be a nut and she shows you by
being weird.
Not necessarily destroying stuff,
but you know,
just the being weird little things by
nibbling at your finger different way
with just her little front teeth.
Like sorta like telling you something
like,
hey dude,
I need to fuck and get some exercise in
and we're all that.
We're where we are that same way.
So our brain is going to make more
complex ways for us to be freaked out.
Basically run for our lives,
right?
Like if I don't just,
I mean again,
I barely do cardio but I do do it pretty
consistently,
but it's short.
It's like a mile or two.
That's all you need.
Real.
Yeah.
But.
And it cleanses the palate.
It's like ginger between Sushi slices
and,
and if I go without it,
absolutely it compiles.
I'll wake up bitter and angry about
something.
I'll see something on you know somewhere
something or you're workwise and stress
out about it and like why?
Oh well this and that and stuff
doesn't make any sense at all.
Yeah.
And if you were in a good state of mind,
you'd be like,
Eh,
who gives a fuck?
Exactly.
But instead you dwell on it.
Yeah.
So your brain's like trying to come up
with problems.
Yeah,
because he wants us to do something.
My Dog Marshall's like that hardcore
because Marshall's and shape,
because he runs miles with me all the
time so that dog's ready to go.
And so it's like we're running,
right?
We're running today.
I'm like,
no,
not today dude.
I got to work.
Fuck am I gonna do with myself,
right.
I'll just start chewing socks and you
know,
doing things that he's not supposed to
do.
He just,
you know,
he's just a ball of energy,
but a lease he doesn't have like anxiety
and negative chatter.
The complex human mind when it doesn't
have enough energy output,
I always think of the brain is almost
like a battery that has a lid on it and
it's like energy is flowing out of the
battery and spilling over the sides and
causing a mess because you gotta expand
or expand a certain amount of energy
every day in order to keep it clean,
just to keep everything going.
Well,
yeah,
dude,
I feel fucking great other than the fact
that I can't walk.
Good.
Yeah,
but it's just.
I went too hard.
It's just too hard,
but I wanted to get so far ahead.
My goal was to get so far ahead that no
one could catch up was like I just,
they could do these big days.
Every now and then I go,
but it's hard to do a big day and then
do another big day and then do another
big day.
That's what's hard and that's where I'll
get them.
I'll get them in the like the like when
you wake up you're like,
not today.
That's the day you got to go.
That's like I'd wanted to put some
distance between them.
So what I did was I did one day where I
did six hours.
I did five hours in the morning and then
I actually five and a half.
Then I did another hour at night,
so it was basically six and a half hours
and I got a thousand points for the day
and they were like,
what the thousand,
35 actually
guarantee you that when Marin was
hearing those voices during that
Kennison time that he wasn't working
out.
No,
he doesn't work it out now and I think
it's easy for a comedian and not work
out and then when you factor that in
that it's not a normal job and you can
go from your bed to your car,
to the venue to sit down.
At a table to wait till you go onstage,
then you do that.
You stand up.
I don't think that had anything to do
with it.
I think it was cocaine.
They did so much cocaine.
They were up for days.
That's what it was.
He broke his brain and physically not
doing anything right.
That too.
But I mean I think the big factor was
the cocaine doing cocaine with Kennison.
I think he just popped a fuse.
You imagine fucking up for days and days
and kinases like where's the blood?
Where's the blood?
And you're like,
I'm only 22,
man.
I gotta get Outta here.
I have a future.
I have a life.
Oh Man.
You know,
he,
he.
Do you know that he kennison and
Roseanne have something really serious
in common.
They were both hit by cars when they're
very young and their personality
radically changed.
Wow.
Yeah.
And that was one of the things that I
really wanted to cover with Rosanne when
I had her on the podcast because all
these people were calling her a racist
and all right,
and this and that and all these
different things.
I'm like,
listen,
you don't understand this woman,
first of all,
one of the greatest standup comics of
all time.
Yup.
Second,
mentally ill and talks about it openly
and is very honest about her troubles
and what happened.
She was committed to a mental
institution for nine months after this
car accident.
I mean she was hitting the fucking head
by a car.
The car was driving,
the sunlight was in her face.
She couldn't see clip during the
intersection,
sent her flying.
She was in intensive care for a long
fucking time in a coma for a long
fucking time payment out of it was
fucked up,
couldn't concentrate in school,
and then he committed her to a mental
institution for nine months.
Could lead name.
That is a long time.
Yeah,
the hood ornament spiked her fucking
head.
Yeah.
So when people are talking about her,
like this is all something that she
planned out because she's an evil
person.
That's like saying to a person who has a
broken leg,
why you limping?
Yeah.
It's really like that.
Like one of the reasons why she was so
brilliant as a comedian other than she
worked hard and she writes and she just
got a great mind for it.
One of the reasons was she truly was
like incredibly impulsive and insane and
this is what allowed her to say things
that other people wouldn't say.
Especially back then.
Like people have to realize when
Roseanne Barr was huge and she was huge
before I ever did comedy.
She was huge.
When she was huge,
there was no women like her.
No one.
She was fat.
She didn't give a fuck.
She would go onstage.
You should talk mad shit would be
hilarious.
She would kill.
She would kill dude.
I remember watching her kill like on Hbo
when I was like probably like 18 or
something like that.
He's want to Mitsis true like success
stories.
Right.
Did you guys talk about that?
Her being on in the main room and then
being on like Carson weeks later she
booked Carson and one of her posts about
that the first time we might not have.
Yeah.
It's hard to remember these.
A comedy store,
like for comedy store fans and
historians,
she's like an anomaly because I'm pretty
sure her first ever spot as a paid
regular was in the main room,
which was a big deal at the time and
from that spot she got the tonight show
like a week or two later,
like she got booked from her first paid
regular spot to the tonight show from
the tonight show.
Goddess sitcoms like was a huge
overnight success.
So it all went like bing,
bing.
Burl.
Yeah.
That one thing that you talked about the
first time she did the POC,
Jasper,
that she lost her mind when all that was
going on.
She was like,
oh,
I went crazy.
I lost my mind.
That kind of pressure to go from being a
housewife and Denver until like a couple
of years later being one of the biggest
stars in the world like that.
Yeah.
There's no the APP it takes,
it takes.
Oh yeah.
That would drive anybody crazy.
The whole thing's crazy because also
waiting for it's crazy and working
towards it's crazy and the whole thing's
crazy,
so to get it all at once,
that seems crazier than anything because
then you're like,
oh my God,
I'm not ready for this.
What am I going to do?
At least most of the time in show
business,
right?
It takes 10,
15,
20,
25 years,
sit in.
You're usually like,
um,
I've been ready for this.
Or you do all those years and then
you're an oversight overnight.
Success like Tiffany Haddish,
right?
Tiffany haddish did a bunch of years and
then out of nowhere she becomes this
giant success.
Yeah.
You know,
but she prepared by doing all those
years for Roseanne.
Barr was like instantaneous.
You know,
the thing that bothered me most about
all that stuff was how quickly everyone
wanted to just cancel her,
get rid of her,
like stop her from working ever again.
Do I don't want to hear her side of it.
There's no room for explanation.
There's no room for discussion.
There's no room for this.
Just get rid of her.
We went from wanting to see people
become stars.
American idol.
America's got talent to watching
people's dreams get destroyed.
That's the new obsession.
The new thing is we've seen people make
it.
Let's watch the dream.
Get crushed.
You are already rich.
Get outta here.
Roseanne,
get outta here.
Kanye.
It's like these people.
I mean,
except for trump.
I mean trump's,
its own thing,
but like trying to like destroy people
that are artists is,
it's the weirdest thing.
Well,
it's
hold that are on the outside that are
watching these people live these
spectacular lives and if,
if something goes wrong,
they're happy because then that person
has to be a regular person again or even
worse.
They have to be a.
has been.
Which people love.
People love a hospital.
Yeah.
I can remember one guy was shitting on
Gary Coleman because Gary Coleman was
the security guard.
I was having this conversation with
them.
He's like laughing that uh,
Gary Coleman from different strokes.
That was the show was a security guard
and he's like,
that fucking guy,
a security guard now man.
And I was like,
okay,
but if you saw like a regular security
guard,
would you go,
ha fucking guys security guard,
you wouldn't do that,
right?
You'd go,
oh,
there's a security guard.
Hey,
what's up man?
Yeah,
I'm going to building three.
Here's my id.
It'd be normal.
Right?
But because he was famous being security
cards a joke and he's a loser.
Like there was joy in glee and this guy
describing how Gary Coleman,
who is born with the disease mean these
deformed,
these tiny person with a fucked up body
has his whole body's a mess.
I mean,
he's a,
he's physically a,
his health is fucked up.
And this guy was taking joy out of the
fact that he was a security guard now.
I was like,
wow,
this is.
There's a weird tendency that people
have to wait to watch people that they
think had it better than them fall.
Yeah.
The guy that,
uh,
was bagging groceries from
whatchamacallits.
What does that.
The cosby show?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
Apparently Tyler Perry gave that guy a
job.
Oh,
shout out to Tyler Perry.
Okay.
Yeah,
he said was the guy is a grocery bag
double the money?
Yeah,
no,
he said,
I love the fact that guys hustling.
He's out there working.
There's no shame in working.
Right.
The fact that people are so obsessed
with that,
that there is a.
there's a shame in it is a shame and
just having a job and working.
It's very strange.
It's very strange how people are
attached to that.
You know,
that they,
they,
they immediately think that this is
something to mock and make fun of.
You know?
I mean,
it was almost universal.
So many people were doing stories on
that guy bagging groceries.
Yeah.
It's the age we live in,
man.
People want to see people break.
If anybody's doing anything,
there's a chance.
They're just waiting.
May people are so mad.
Look if,
if Megan Kelly,
if we didn't know what her contract was,
right?
If it was just some,
in fact,
let's say we did know and let's say she
was getting paid barely what we would
ever guess,
right?
Let's say she's getting paid,
I don't know,
100,000
dollars a year at her new job at NBC.
She'd probably still have the jobs.
Right?
I mean it's the whole crazy part is that
we all know she got paid $68,000,000
for three years.
For what?
Right.
That's the whole take.
So it's like analyze and get.
You know what people are watching.
Like what'd she just say about Halloween
costume.
That's it.
We got it.
We got her.
Yeah.
Did you ever hear it?
Play it Meghan.
Kelly Shit.
Which you guys have bundle.
Which comment?
Like the apology or the original?
No,
apologies.
It was hilarious.
This woman said that some woman from
Australia said that it seems like a
hostage video.
The only thing that's missing is her
holding up a newspaper with a date on
it.
I retweeted La is soda and then somebody
else said if there's one of the.
One of the things about it that's so
strange is how insincere seems like
forced,
like some of forrester.
Tara apology.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
He apologized for it.
Now I haven't seen that,
but the Brits forget the apology.
Let's play the actual video.
Actually I remember,
if I remember correctly,
it's two comments.
She makes one and then they come back.
Oh really?
I think the second comment I think was
the real issue.
Yeah.
What was the first comment?
I don't remember.
So there was a controversy on the real
housewives of New York with Luanne.
If she dresses Diana Ross and she made
her skin look darker than it really is,
and people said that that was racist and
I don't know.
I felt like.
Who doesn't love Diana Ross?
She wants to look like Diana Ross for
one day and I don't know how that got
racist on Halloween.
It appeared to be.
See that's the first one is it?
But it's weird when you watch it now,
like you know,
this is her demise,
like you're watching the stumble when
she trips off the rock and falls off the
cliff.
This is the stumble,
like I don't get it.
How is that racist to want to be Diana
Ross then play it again?
Yeah.
Halloween,
like I was a kid.
That was okay.
As long as you were dressing up as
characters
and that was just some guys commentary
from Wall Street Journal that was a wrap
and also have my favorite one of hers
that she ever said.
No.
My favorite one of hers that she.
We're good.
Yeah.
My favorite one of her she ever said was
they were doing this thing on Fox News
about Santa Claus and someone had
something about Santa Claus being black.
They did something about Santa Claus
being black and she just went,
oh well Santa Claus is definitely white,
and she was like,
I think she sent it to kids like kids.
Santa Claus is definitely right.
Or kids.
Santa Claus is real and he's definitely
white.
I forget what the exact terminology was,
but she basically said Santa clauses.
Definitely white like Santa Claus in
fucking real.
Okay.
That's like saying Spiderman is
definitely white.
She didn't get fired from Fox for saying
that.
She probably got a raise for saying that
they licked her toes.
Whole different thing at Fox.
Well,
it was.
Then they don't want to know.
Yeah.
She wanted to go back.
No,
no,
we're good.
Yeah,
they want him to take her back.
The thing is you can't go from being an
ice princess and the conservative right
wing channel to being like Oprah would.
She's trying to be like Oprah.
I don't.
I.
I'll never really get what MBC was
thinking.
They're thinking Shewchuk.
He was just going to come over.
That's exactly what they thought.
They thought she has a giant fan base,
but she had a fan base for sure.
Some came over,
but she,
a lot of her fan base was because she
was the beautiful conservative woman who
was a very tough,
very articulate,
very smart,
you know,
and they liked that she was an ice
princess and she would shut people down
if they're incorrect and she wouldn't
let people talk over her.
She was powerful.
Kind of frightening in a hot way.
Yeah.
Fox News
has a bunch of those checks just
waiting,
waiting in the helm
like that closet x market.
Now when the dude opens it up and sees,
saw these robots with different skin and
faces,
they have so many of them.
Just teleprompters ready to roll.
Big,
big letters that they can read it
clearly.
We'll tell you what you like.
Yeah.
They're making a movie and these three
are the,
uh,
the anchors on Fox News,
Robbie,
Nicole Kidman,
and uh,
and Megan Kelly on.
Yeah.
Might be on the other end of the Porta
potty.
Dare you see.
You could get fired for that.
Imagine if you were on a show and you
said that that would be the end like
that.
This is a beautiful thing about podcast.
Nobody gives a fuck that you said that
it has zero consequences.
But like,
let's,
let's pretend that you were on the
tonight show and you were a guest and
you'll be in the end of that port.
A potty people.
Oh,
did he really?
Really?
That one was just trying to go to the
restroom.
You think that's funny?
It's crazy.
What's happening.
I've noticed it a little bit and stand
up lately.
There's been a couple of these road
trips.
I did something that you told me not to
do.
Joe Rogan.
You ready for this?
You told me not to do it years ago when
I did it and it was rough and I
performed stand up comedy in
Connecticut.
Is that right?
You were right,
dude.
I told you you your place of despair.
It's really crazy.
So one of the things that happened was,
is I noticed this really cool old guy
stood out in the front,
middle of the audience.
Right?
And I'm like,
you seem like at a place and cool as
hell and oldest.
Fuck,
what's your story,
dude?
Right.
And I noticed that there's this angry
older lady almost like almost like Dana
carvey church lady character sitting
next to him and I go and who's this
angry lady that you're sitting next to?
She doesn't want to be here at all.
And he goes,
that's my wife.
And they were the most different seeming
couple you could ever imagine.
This happy,
smiling,
laughing and everything guy in just
this.
I mean she was looking at me with hate,
not just not having fun.
She hated me.
It could have been something that I
talked about early on.
Maybe it was like a.
something about your Amy Schumer,
Joe could have been,
that could have been my me to Joe,
could have been my,
uh,
trump misdirect joke that people,
you know what I mean anyway.
And,
but I noticed next to them there's this
girl who seems even angrier than the mom
and they're the only two angry people in
the room and it's a Gig at a casino in
Connecticut and give me a face just
literally like literally like a modern
day,
like if said to a bad actress,
like play angry,
play angry,
angrier and angrier to a horrible
actress like that.
And uh,
and,
and I go and I go,
what's the problem?
And you know,
there's like the,
I ignore it for like 45 minutes,
right?
And I'm going on and on.
But the mom's angry.
It turns out that the chick next to
them's the daughter and the.
And they're basically mad because of
whatever,
whatever material or whatever.
And I ended up towards the end of my
[inaudible] going off on the girl.
I go,
Hey,
I go take this scowl on your face.
What are you doing?
Do you think that's going to affect me,
lady,
I'm getting paid the same amount whether
you laugh or not and I'm back.
Dell lay back to the dream tomorrow.
You know what I mean?
Like at this point I'm just,
my fans are loving it and they're the
ones that stumbled into the wrong scene
over the wrong show at the wrong time.
If they were looking for Christian
puppet comedy or whatever,
and I said to her,
I go,
you seem like A.
you seem like an Internet troll that
just stumbled in here like you seem like
you're gonna write about this.
You seem like the type of angry where
you think you're gonna change something
or you're going to do something to my
career.
That's what I.
that's the Vibe I get from you.
I literally made the jokes,
the crowds loving it by the way.
You know what I mean?
Because they can tell like it's not
anything to you or is she just.
There was wondering.
There was one part where I go,
I go Mike,
because my goal,
the thing that,
the reason why I ignored them for a
while was because I go,
you seem like a tough lady to the mom.
Right?
I go,
you seem tough,
but I'm going to break you at some point
during this set and when I do,
I'm going to make sure this whole room
knows.
I'm going to say I gotcha.
And I'm not going to tell you when it's
gonna happen,
but I'm going to make you laugh anyway.
Forty five minutes later I get to the
point to where I had in my mind set up
that there's no way she's not going to
laugh at this and sure enough I got a
big smile out of her.
Right?
I'm not,
I won't say what the joke is.
I don't want to give anything away,
but I got the smile and I'm literally
like.
And the whole crowd's already laughing
and they can tell that I'm looking to
watch to see if the lady breaks and she
doesn't.
And I go,
how in the.
I thought I was gonna get ya.
I thought I was gonna get shot.
That one.
How is it possible that you don't laugh
at that?
Like what do you do for Fun Lady?
Like at this point I'm just all amped up
and I go,
what would I have to do to possibly make
you laugh?
And that's finally when the angry
daughter goes,
be funny.
I go,
oh no,
I've been killing for 52 minutes now.
You know what I mean?
Like at this point,
whatever.
There's everybody else,
the 99 point nine percent of the other
audiences,
the witness at this point in there
against this chick,
right?
Because this chick's now just mad
because whatever,
and,
and I go,
you seem like the type of girl that
thinks that you can even affect an
artist.
You know what I mean?
This is this little millennial nerdy
girl and sure enough,
sure enough,
I go on twitter later that night,
they're the at,
at Mohegan Sun.
You should not be promoting this
comedian,
Barbara,
Barbara.
Two days later my manager gets an email
and he's like,
dude,
we got this email from some lady in
Connecticut,
so meaner on stage.
I'm like,
she wrote you a letter was like,
it's three paragraphs long.
I'm like,
what is happening?
Like I mean,
what is happening in this world where
someone's taking the time to write a
letter to my manager of all people.
Who by the way is the laughing at the
whole thing.
If you manage it,
dumped you for that like enough,
right?
One audience member in Connecticut and
then hold the crowd.
Ninety nine percent thought you were
funny,
but that's not good enough.
Yeah.
I need 100 percent,
but man,
you were right in Connecticut is weird.
It's a weird place.
You could run into a person like that
anywhere.
Yeah.
I mean I've run into people like that at
the store.
They sit in the front row with her,
arms crossed.
You're going to run into people like
that everywhere,
but there's something about Connecticut
where it's no real cities.
You've got Hartford,
which is a land of despair and you've
got new haven which is worse and it's
just a highway between Boston and New
York,
so all it is the Boston's great.
New York's great.
Connecticut's like,
what the fuck are you doing here?
What's going on here?
It's become such a running joke that lex
Friedman,
the scientists from Mit who's on here
the other day to talk about artificial
intelligence.
He brought it up as a joke.
What did he say?
You remember what he said something
about like he just wanted you to shit on
it.
I don't remember exactly what I did.
I did so many gigs in Connecticut,
so many,
so many because I lived in Boston and it
was like an hour and a half drive to our
drive.
You're in Connecticut.
We did a lot of gigs there.
Greg Fitzsimmons and I,
we did a shit ton of gigs in
Connecticut.
We'd always leave going.
What the fuck was that?
It was felt.
It felt dirty.
It's a Gig I did purely for the money.
Some of them are good and my good friend
Tommy Junior lives in Connecticut.
There's good people in Connecticut.
Sun All bad,
but it's disproportionately bad.
That's the problem.
It's not that everyone in Connecticut is
full of despair.
No means a lot of people that live in
Hartford and not Hartford,
but what's that area outside of New York
City where all the rich people live?
Greenwich.
That's where Vince Mcmahon Lips.
Super Rich.
Like estates?
Yeah.
Like David Letterman has a spot out
there.
I mean like you got to drive like a mile
to get to the property down their
driveway.
The driveway was like a mile of like
manicured lawns.
They have those great gatsby type
residence there.
Hell yeah.
A lot of pills.
A lot of people pilled up.
Yeah.
Look at these joints is the average
house.
Wow.
Look at these joints.
That's not real,
but it's being built.
Dam.
Those are the apartment buildings,
but it's a house.
Let me see a house.
See,
that's a house.
That's a Connecticut House dude.
There's insane amounts of finance money.
Like that's great.
Gatsby type shit.
Did you ever read the Great Gatsby?
I uh,
I watched the movie.
I was supposed to read the book as a
student.
The dicaprio movies actually.
Pretty fucking good.
Yeah.
Really good.
Great Soundtrack.
Yeah.
And it was weird too,
because it's like they took artistic
license with like the way the
automobiles worked and moved and there
was like a lot of flair to it that made
it exciting.
Beautiful movie.
One of those ones where you got to turn
out the lights,
make sure your color on your tvs right
and turn up the sound.
Yeah.
But that's that area.
That area of Connecticut is just
unbelievably wealthy.
That area of Connecticut.
And there's another area that's similar
to that in Long Island.
Like that's the Hamptons.
The hamptons in Long Island is all just
insane wealth.
Just like Matt Lauer has a house out
there that's like $16,000,000
on the today show money.
Holla,
man.
He's doing it.
He's not.
What is he going to do?
We think they're good.
I can make a comeback.
Ah,
I think.
No,
I think he's gonna be like selling
things any day now.
Like how like Larry King now like sells
things like on late night tv ever see
that?
Was he selling Larry King's like sling
and like fake products and stuff.
They're Kingston's a show,
sort of a mixture of an advertisement.
Is a show on television or is it on the
Internet?
I think it's on the Internet and it was
just on it.
Really?
Yeah.
I'm talking about they know what you're
talking about.
The TV that looks like a TV show,
but it's for them not a TV show.
It's really just a.
he's like asking questions like he used
to do,
but it's just some guy like.
Yes.
And another thing might prostate
medicine can do.
Oh,
right,
right.
It's on the same set.
That's why I'm saying that.
I guess.
Here's the set of his show.
It's on aura tv,
but he shoots those commercials on that
wooden background said,
oh,
okay.
So they just have a similar setup.
Who's that girl in the upper right hand
corner?
What is that?
What is that trick?
Seem to.
What in the hell am I?
Watch drag queen.
What?
Go go full screen please.
Oh,
look at her eyes.
That's insane.
Oh Shit.
What's going on there with the eyes?
I'm confused.
Lots of tents.
Makeup and.
But wait a minute,
I don't know where her actual eyes.
Somewhere in there.
Whoa.
That's a drag queen.
It's like,
oh,
it's Kinda like she's like a true on
extra lashes or something.
But she also drew white underneath the
eyes.
There you go.
And then black.
Oh my God.
That's insanity.
Those the craziest eyes have ever seen
in my life.
Eyebrows going away.
Up.
Yeah.
Well the,
the black triangles in the corners of
the eyes to that is the nuttiest makeup
and look at the cheekbones,
like how sculpted it is,
where it's like it has an abrupt line
before the lower jaw.
Like a spray painted with the same
person.
That's crazy.
Larry King's was trying to play it.
Cool.
He can't even tell he's blind.
He doesn't even know he's looking at
yellow.
Great makeup.
Lovely.
So how long have you been at man?
I'm a woman.
I've always been a woman.
Oh Yeah?
Yeah.
I forgot.
He's born in the 19 hundreds.
Men who didn't know shit back then.
Larry King's washed it all happened,
man.
Dude.
Larry King went to the pokey pokey.
The jail.
Larry King went to jail.
Yeah,
there she is.
Slow.
Whoa,
look at that makeup man.
God,
she looks like a pink floyd album
covers.
How is that even real?
But she's got a signature look though.
I'll tell you that.
That's her.
Look,
she wears all these pictures.
Have that triangle thing.
I'm scared to have her in here.
What does she look like without makeup?
Right there?
What does she live?
What do you think she looks like?
Probably like me.
Probably better looking than you.
Maybe look into the camera.
Tony.
I'm sorry.
Yeah,
maybe a picture me with cat eyes.
Not Cat eyes.
That was a cat.
I'd shoot it right in the fucking head.
Has An evil cat.
Um,
what did Larry King go to jail for?
Went to jail for something that's crazy.
Uh,
like it looks like he's all coked up in
his mugshot photo.
It looks like a wild man.
Grand Larceny.
Oh Damn.
Yeah.
Look at him.
What is the grand larceny bad?
I like money laundering.
Larry King was into some ozone shit
cooked out of his mind.
Look at my fucking Miami whores whores.
They had a common sideburns.
It looks fucking amazing.
Nineteen 71.
Wow.
Yeah,
Dude.
I was four years old.
Larry King's getting arrested.
Damn.
Find out what he got arrested for.
What did he do on able to pay back money
he owns?
Oh,
that's it.
he owed a finance here.
He was doing some work for the judge to
route the larceny charge because statute
of limitation run out.
King pled no contest to one count of
passing bad checks.
It's not that bad.
Dade County,
Florida,
that shirt is by the way like they
don't.
They just don't make shirts like that.
Look,
that's just white circles on a black
collared shirt.
You can get those from me.
Undies.
Your Polo shirts like that does
me?
Andy's do shirts.
They do.
Wow.
Yeah.
Damn.
They have lounge pants now and let's.
What's the Promo Code?
I wrote me undies.com.
Forward Slash rogen.
Love it.
Everybody was doing coke back then.
I got assumed Larry King was on coke.
You've seen cocaine cowboys,
right?
Yeah.
Fucking amazing.
Amazing.
Document one into amazing.
When you just realize what you could be,
especially if you're living in Ohio,
like you were or out here in Los
Angeles,
you might not know the history of
cocaine in Miami.
He might not know how fucking insane it
was until you watch that documentary and
you just go,
what?
Yeah,
or Narcos or really,
you know,
narcos is good,
but it's a lot of it is about another
country.
Yeah.
Like cocaine.
Cowboys is almost all about America.
Yeah.
There's one,
one part of cooking cowboys that I'll
never forget what they said,
that the entire graduating class of the
police academy was either murdered or
went to jail.
Wow.
They were all corrupt.
Everybody was doing coke.
There's more banks per capita in Miami
at least at the time,
than anywhere else in the country,
and it was all money laundering saw.
It was fucking hell.
My friend Steve Graham was going to
school in Miami back then.
He was doing his residency in Miami.
He's an ophthalmologist and he was there
during the cocaine violence hears.
So he was doing his residency.
You do emergency room work.
So he was there,
people bullet holes and fucking brain's
exploded.
He said it was crazy.
The amount of violence.
He would say just every night people
would bullet holes and gunshot wounds
and knife wounds and fucking attacked
with barb wire and chaos and a lot of
people with things up their ass.
Railey oh yeah.
All kinds of things.
Light Bulbs.
You know those twisty light bulbs like a
pine cone up the ass.
Can't get it out.
Why would a,
why wouldn't they?
Why light bulbs warm a little bit up.
Shove it in there.
Start beating off.
Can't get it out there to get to the
doctor.
How do you drive slow.
I'll put my ass out.
No,
I don't know.
But he told me that that was one of the
things.
They pulled out a guy's ass.
A light bulb.
One of them twisty light bulbs.
That's,
that's the thing too.
Like Gi Joe Dolls.
She liked that.
That's what happens when you have a bad
idea.
A light bulb appears
in your ass instead of over your head.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
That would be actually really fun.
A really fun thing in a movie,
you know,
like a cartoon.
I've got a great idea.
I know.
Oh my God,
thank God we're not Dr.
so yeah,
seriously,
you know,
how morose you would get your everyday
you're dealing with people dying.
They just get too comfortable with it
and you have to save them no matter
what.
I was reading last night about the,
uh,
about the uh,
Jewish doctor who had the shooter of
the,
of the temple in Pittsburgh.
He had to save his life.
He had to like make sure that he's okay.
You know what I mean?
Sometimes you're just helping horrible
human beings that just slaughtered some
of your own people.
Now you're a Jewish doctor.
Happened to fix the guy.
Now in our World Tarantino world,
we like to think that,
oh,
so sorry to accidentally,
it appears as if though I haven't given
you the right medicine.
You know what I mean?
But in real life they have to just
stitch them up and
you know,
well,
it also mean that guy probably has a
record is in terms of what is success
ratio.
He doesn't want to fuck it up for some
asshole.
Right?
Oh yeah.
It seems like being a doctor would be
very,
very hard.
Like as a mentally it seems like racking
up those losses and such a lack of
control.
The human body,
emt workers to.
Yeah,
same kind of deal.
A buddy of mine told me,
I'm never date a female emt worker.
I go,
why?
And he goes,
they're crazy.
He goes,
they've seen so much violence.
They just fuck everyone.
I go,
what?
And he goes,
yeah,
this is a bunch of female emt workers
that they work with.
They're just bang everybody.
Obviously it's not every emt female
worker because he's just my asshole
friend telling me this based on his very
limited polling,
but my thought on it is to you imagine
how fleeting you would feel that life
is.
If every day you're seeing people die
everyday you're dealing with car
accidents,
you're showing up.
People's brains are splattered all over
the highway.
Their legs are ripped off.
They've been run over by trucks every
day,
all day long.
And this was what he.
He said,
he goes,
first of all,
no one's supposed to see that much
death.
He goes,
if you see that much death,
it rewires the way your brain works.
He goes,
you're supposed to see that.
Supposed to see that.
Very rarely,
very rarely in life.
We see it every day.
It's like something goes wrong,
and he goes,
it's been my experience that some of
these women with that goes wrong.
They just,
they're just wild.
That is,
fuck everybody,
God.
I go,
Whoa,
but why do you think they're doing it?
And he's like too distracting
themselves,
trying to distract themselves from the
violence.
Again,
this is one asshole friend if you're
listening to like,
Fuck Tony Hinchcliffe and Joe Rogan.
I can't believe you brought that up.
I'm an emt worker.
I'm a mom.
I'm a great person.
I'm sure you are ma'am.
I'm talking about the east
to fuck like an animal and you know it.
That's how those babies were made.
Wow.
How dare you hit that.
It seems to make sense to me that female
emt would be a pretty horned up cops to.
Oh,
for sure.
Cops.
Yeah.
I watched a porno the other day,
two female cops getting banged by the
black guy.
They were supposed to arrest.
Of course that happens.
It must happen.
Happens with guards in jail.
Female guards.
Remember those guys that escaped?
One of them was banging the guard and
upstate New York.
They flew to fleet to Canada.
Some fugly looking female guard dude was
throwing dicker way.
The guard left with the prisoner.
Didn't she bring him the stuff to help
them break out?
Right and saw or something,
and then she turned herself in.
She couldn't handle it anymore.
Fucking ramp.
The alarms are going off in.
The manhunt was underway like,
how did he get out?
She's like,
oh wow.
Imagine that you're a prisoner.
It is.
Look at her.
Joyce Mitchell denied parole after
helping killer inmates escaped New York
prison.
Going to jail herself.
That's the look of a lady that messed up
after getting good Dick.
There was a guy I used to spar with
who was a security guard at jail and
that was fucking with his head too.
He was just telling me about what the
experience was like.
Like every day you're just always
dealing with these fucking people that
they're never getting out of there.
Like he was in a maximum security
penitentiary,
so like they're never getting out of
there every day.
Every day you're just dealing with
horrible people in terrible
circumstances and they know that you get
to leave.
They know you get to leave,
but you're living with them.
Most of the day goes,
yeah,
I'm not a prisoner.
He goes,
but my environment is surrounded by
these people.
He's like,
that affects you.
It's like,
I never thought about it that way.
I always thought the guards have it.
Okay.
It's just a job.
Whereas the inmates,
you know well those poor bastards are
stuck in there while you're in there
with them for eight hours a day.
Most of the time you're not controlling
them most of the time.
You just coexisting.
Yeah.
Who's behind the bars?
Which,
which way is behind?
Right?
Right there in a cell with a hallway
filled with bars.
People,
one person on the other side of each
bar.
So are they the same exact thing and
then they're wearing body armor and
fucking they have clubs and they always
terrified that a riot is going to break
out.
You saw Whitey bulger got killed.
He did,
yeah.
When?
Yesterday in prison sentence for them.
And like first day,
first day hold that guy,
that guy that hates rats killed him in
Italian guy or like a gangster guy.
Really?
That guy I read,
the guy,
uh,
is obsessed with hating rats and hating
people that beat.
And I guess Whitey killed women.
This guy,
the first chance he got
Whitey Bulger,
met a violent end after a lifetime of
brutality.
They,
they tried to pull his eyes out of his
skull.
Whoa.
I don't know if they were successful or
not.
The thing I read
didn't make it larger so I could read
that.
And what does it say in a three foot
grave near a river,
not far from Boston,
Pat mcgonigal's body laid,
decaying,
undisturbed until his remains were found
20 years later,
part of his pelvic bone,
fractured skull and decompose brain
matter or bringing,
oh,
okay.
This is all the different things that
he's done.
Yeah,
yeah.
Now he was a horrible fucking killer.
West Virginia.
After he transferred,
you know,
I used to train a guy that was one of
his fucking mom,
henchmen guy said to me once,
he goes,
if you're going to kill somebody,
how would you kill him as a with my bare
hands?
He goes,
yeah,
I go,
I probably hit him in the neck.
Was like,
yeah.
I was like,
okay.
That was scary until you find out that's
the end of the conversation.
I was 19 at the time when I was teaching
taekwondo,
when I was teaching this guy who,
um,
he was friends with a friend of mine who
absolutely worked for Whitey Bulger who
wound up going to jail.
And they told me that this guy used to
whack people.
I was like,
oh Jesus Christ.
And I was teaching him type window.
He was very serious,
like a WHO's very intense.
And I was very aware that there was
something different about him and it
goes very aware,
like he wasn't just a guy that was
learning for exercise or self defense
want to take a little class,
is learn a little martial arts.
He was gonna use it like he was a guy
that was in case he needed to use it.
You know what I'm saying?
Like there's,
there's a mindset of someone who just
wants to get better at a martial art and
there's a mindset of someone who's
thinking about,
okay,
it's going to come down.
I'm going to fuck him right there.
Okay.
And I'm going to kill that guy.
Was like,
when he would practice,
there was a,
there was a certain amount of focus and
intensity that he had.
That was palpable.
Yeah.
Mobsters need to get better at,
uh,
at that type of stuff.
Do you ever see,
remember Deniros kicks in?
Goodfellas.
Those just sloppy this straight down the
middle.
What's this?
Why do you boulders fader that did it?
Yeah.
He was unrecognizable less ago.
Did it?
Bam.
Right.
Mr.
Bulges eyes appeared to have been
dislodged from his head.
Although it was unclear whether his
attackers gouged them out or they were
knocked out because he was beaten so
severely in the attack.
This information was relayed by senior
law enforcement official who oversees
organized crime cases.
Oh,
that's what it was.
It was a padlock stuffed.
A sock.
Oh,
that's what they beat them with.
Yup.
And they also pulled his eyes out of his
head,
at least in part with a padlock that was
stuffed inside of us suck.
At least two inmates were quickly sent
to solitary confinement after Mr Bolger
was found according to three employees
of the Federal Bureau of prisons.
Wow.
Damn.
Yeah.
Well,
couldn't happen to a nicer guy.
Whitey bulger.
Do you know he won the lottery twice?
Really?
Yup.
Not really a scam.
I mean,
that was,
that was how he,
um,
he would show his income so someone else
would win the lottery and they would
come to him and he would like give them
the money and they would give them a
lottery ticket and he'd be like,
look,
I won the lottery.
That's how I'm rich.
Yeah.
It dark like they probably would find
the person who won the lottery,
you know,
they chase Dana white out of town.
Do you know that?
No.
Yeah,
yeah,
they,
they wanted money.
They wanted payment from Dan and white
and uh,
Dana White got beaten up by them so
severely that he had tinnitus in his
ears.
Fuck yeah.
He had a fucking.
He had a jet out of town.
He moved to Vegas.
Wow.
Yeah,
because they want her to cut of the UFC.
No,
it wasn't the UFC.
There was no ufc back then.
He was like a boxing trainer.
Oh,
I forget what he was doing,
whether he's running a gym,
but he had to leave town because the
mom.
That's why he left Boston.
Yeah,
it was real man.
I mean this was all when I was a kid.
I mean I got seriously into taekwondo in
1982.
That's when it became like 81,
82.
That's when it really became like my
whole life.
And that's right around the time where
all that shit was going on.
And then when in 1988,
I became friends with a comedian who was
his brother went to jail for being a
part of Whitey bulger's mom.
Yeah.
Crazy.
It was like everybody knew somebody who
was in some way connected to the mob in
some way.
You know,
I just.
One Dude,
one here,
crazy story.
There's one guy,
he's dead now.
I could talk about him.
His name is richie and he went to jail.
Um,
while I knew him,
he was arrested for a murder that I
don't think they ever got him on.
But this person who was killed wasn't
just killed.
They broke every bone in his body with a
hammer and kept injecting him with
cocaine to keep them awake.
Yeah.
So he would black out from the pain and
they would inject him with cocaine to
wake them back up again.
And then they would break another bone.
They're breaking all of his bones with a
hammer.
They cut his hands off,
cut his head off,
they cut everything off.
And then when they found,
you know,
is broken heap of a body.
He was somehow connected to this guy
that I knew sold coke and this guy had
gone to jail and uh,
I knew him before he went to jail.
He was another guy from taekwondo.
He was one person.
He was a young guy.
I was,
I think when he went to jail I was 16
and I think he was 20 and then when he
got out of jail it was,
I was 20 and he was 24 and he had scars
all over his body where he tried to,
uh,
like sand off his,
his tattoos.
He had tattoos all over his arms and I
don't know what the tattoos were,
whether they were racist or whether he
just didn't want him anymore,
but he had like either acid burns or
scars,
like what are,
how are the fuck?
He tried to get the tattoos all over his
arms.
His arms are covered in scars and he
wasn't good.
He wasn't like a,
a talented martial artists,
but he was insanely tough,
like insanely aggressive and insanely
tough.
And when you sparred him,
you were fighting for your life,
for your life.
He would come at me and try to fucking
kill me.
I mean fucking kill you,
throwing looping punches with every
fucking ounce of his being.
And I'm moving around and I'm like,
oh,
we're fighting to the death here.
We're fighting.
This is not,
this is not sparring.
We only spotted a couple of times before
this.
But one time he had me cornered.
He trapped me in a corner and hit me
with a fucking bomb on the top of my
head.
Just boom,
like as hard as he could.
But he was a strong guy who's quite a
bit bigger than me to Irish guy.
I think he was Italian.
Um,
and uh,
I kicked him in the head so hard.
It broke his cheek,
like his cheek shifted over his face.
I will kicked him.
So I hit him with my heel and his face
and he dropped down.
He collapsed,
went down to is like,
like went down face first,
got up on his all fours,
got back up again,
wanting to keep going.
And I said,
I go,
Richie,
you got to look in the mirror.
I go,
come look in the mirror.
And he's like,
oh fuck.
I go,
yeah,
you can't spar anymore,
dude.
He wanted to kill me.
He wanted to keep going.
You want to keep going.
After I basically kicked his face in
half.
Jesus,
I hit him so hard.
It wasn't a sparring session.
It was an I'm trying to kill you.
You're trying to kill me session.
And I remember setting them upset and
I'm upset and I'm up.
And I hit him with that thing and he
face planted.
Most people would have just went out,
but he was so angry and so mean.
He was trying to get up.
It's fucking scary.
That was,
I was the last time I sparred with him,
I'm like,
we're not sparring anymore,
dude.
I'm not not fighting the death with some
guy who I'm kind of friendly with.
I was friendly with them.
Other than that,
like what was you would never guess.
Remember one time we went out,
it was me and him and these two girls
and they were like real weird,
right?
And uh,
you know,
this one girl was like a,
like Richie,
when are we going to get that stuff?
I go,
what stuff you're going to get in.
He's like a.
and she's like,
he's going to get us some coke or you
don't want a coke?
She goes,
fuck you.
Trying to tell her she doesn't want
coke.
She's like,
that's why I'm here.
That's why I'm hanging out with this
guy.
Stupid.
That's so funny.
Yeah,
it was one of the rare times I hung out
with them outside of the gym.
He told me a story about how he had a
fight off these guys with a broomstick
in jail and now he's beaten these guys
to death with a broomstick.
Just this horrible story about him being
forced to mop up something in a bathroom
and these guys cornered them and he's
just fucking attacking them with this
broomstick and about how you got extra
time for that.
I forget what he went to jail for.
I assume it's probably drug related.
I don't remember what it was,
but I remember just being so nervous
about being connected to people like
that,
like knowing people like that from the
gym because there's people like that.
There were always there always wanted to
learn how to fight.
So because you knew,
you know,
you're teaching martial arts,
you training,
there's always those.
Those guys would always come in whenever
it was time to spar.
Oh,
scary times.
There was no pulling back.
There was no,
like if you respond with some friends,
like I was sparring with like my friend
Leroy Rodriguez,
a good friend of mine who was fast as
lightning is Puerto Rican guy was bad
motherfucker.
But he would not hurt me when we would
spar,
we would go hard,
but he would hold back from hurting you.
You know,
you could trust certain people where you
were sparring.
You knew that it was just sparring.
There was other people.
It was to the death.
It's terrible.
Crazy.
Not only that,
we did it over a fucking thin,
uh,
office carpet on top of concrete.
It was just office carpet on top of
concrete,
so when people would fall,
a kid would bounce off the concrete.
Oh fuck.
Yeah.
It was horrible.
Good Lord.
That's the eighties,
Bro.
She was different.
No good.
So terrible.
So terrible back then,
man.
People like people couldn't get
concussions back then or something.
Oh,
they got him.
They got a lot of them.
Yeah.
I remember people getting them when they
were just fucked up for months and
months at a time.
He'd get mean.
You get that kind of a concussion when
you bounce your head off the ground and
then,
you know,
just the impact of something like that.
It's just,
it's so devastating,
man.
That's just so bad for you.
There's a great video.
Not Great,
but kind of crazy.
If you go to Saxon Moitai,
I'm on instagram.
There's a video of these two guys
fighting in the parking lot and uh,
one guy's obviously a trained fighter
and he's fighting these gang bangers and
uh,
he leg kicks one of them and then
punches him in the face.
And so the guys going,
Oh,
you think you're going to kick?
Boy,
you think you're going to kick homeboy,
and he goes,
come on,
kick me,
motherfucker,
and he takes a puff of the cigarette and
he takes his shirt off.
He's going to fight.
He has no idea how to fight and he's
decided he's going to fight this guy who
knows how to fight and this guy leg
kicks him,
drops him to the ground,
he gets up.
The guy shoots a double lift's his legs
up in the air and dropped him on his
head and he just goes out.
Yeah,
it's so watching.
There's something about watching
someone's head bounce off concrete.
That is so fucking disturbing
for sure.
It's just,
it's.
It's sad or you find it.
Anything else?
Saxxon Moy.
Tai,
you didn't see it.
Maybe somebody pulled it.
Must pull it up.
Let me see it.
I once had a concussion in asc.
The page.
Let me scroll down a little bit.
Hold on.
We'll go to the top again.
Yep,
that's it.
Go scroll down a little bit.
Yeah.
Somebody wants to pull it.
I got an a in a wrestling match.
One time.
Maybe I'm wrong.
Maybe it wasn't sex on,
I threw up Rice Krispie treats
everywhere I was out,
I was unconscious and I was throwing up
rice krispie treats because I loaded up
on those after weigh ins were like an
hour before the match.
I had a peanut butter and jelly and like
the back then they had just debuted,
it was like a new thing,
the premade super processed rice krispie
treats like that.
We're just coming individual packages
and after cutting,
you know,
my weight cuts were horrible,
horrible,
horrible.
And uh,
so like I would just be eyeballing all
this food all week,
you know what I mean.
And I remember I'd be so excited.
Whatever you had,
you'd be so excited for.
And I was way too excited about this
whole box of rice krispie treats that I
had and I probably had like four or five
right before the match and just boom out
like a light.
Some dubious my head.
Yeah,
some dude got my head wrapped up in his
legs like it was,
um,
it was like a,
like almost like a double chicken wing.
Like he had.
He was,
I,
my chest was on the mat,
I think he got me in double chicken
wings and started to walk around my
head,
hit year.
I rolled over and then.
But,
but I was really,
I'm really Bridgie and agile and have a
long neck that I can bridge up on,
so when I bridged up on my neck and he's
just now there's nothing he can do.
He took his leg and swooped it and
figure Ford my head.
So now I'm in a figure four with my head
and double chicken wings.
But then when,
once he did that,
I bridged up again the crowd.
I remember sort of being like,
Ooh,
you know what I mean?
Like it's like you're not pin in May.
And then he did this thing where you
just bucked back like a bull in my head
right into the mat,
out like out like a light.
I was taken off on a stretcher to the
hospital that wrestling match.
It's the only time that ever happened.
How quick after that did you go back to
wrestling?
Oh,
probably probably a week or two or
assistant coaches.
Son had just died,
so like that,
that night was like dedicated to him
because he showed up.
We weren't expecting him to be there.
How's The sun was like leukemia or
something like that and we weren't
expecting him to be there in like our
head coach gave us one of those pep
talks like coach Burton's common tonight
and he's coming after his son dies.
Then you motherfuckers better not give
up.
Like it was one of those like super
crazy,
like beyond all of our human potential,
which is probably why I ended up in that
position in the first place because I'm
just bridging for everything,
including my assistant coaches,
son spirit and all of this.
You know what I mean?
Better not give up.
Right?
Oh,
this is it.
This is the video sent to me on.
Oh,
here it is on Worldstar.
Watch this.
He kept some with the leg kick.
The guy gets up.
Now watch this.
Watch this.
Boom.
Strong leg.
Perfectly timed.
Watch this.
Ah,
out.
Go from the beginning though.
In the beginning you see long.
It's two minutes long.
Yeah.
But at the beginning you see how the
fight starts to this guy,
the guys a come on motherfucker,
you want some of got a shirt off.
And the guys like trying.
He's by himself and he's like,
no,
we'll do one on one.
One on one,
one on one.
He fought another dude first diddy.
Yeah.
This guy,
this guy,
this is the guy legs kicks.
And after he laid kicks,
this dude,
the other guy says,
come on,
keep it over here.
Who doesn't have a wife beater on me?
Some volume on this just isn't going to
get taken down from youtube.
I'm trying to keep.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
Too.
You can turn it down.
So the guy's like,
come on man.
So like this,
just one dude by himself with a bunch of
other dudes.
But he steps in.
This guy knows how to fight.
Look at it as throwing a jab in the
wash.
This leg kick.
Oh.
So there's quite a bit first whole
different guy.
No,
no,
no.
Yeah,
but that's it right there.
Leg kick.
Boom.
Then he cracked some.
And so then the guy's like realizing
he's in trouble.
And so he starts backing away and the
guys coming forward,
he's like,
come on bitch.
And so then the other guy afterwards
goes,
oh,
you think you're going to load,
kick in the leg kick.
So he comes back,
he's like,
tired of this dude walking away from him
and he's like,
I fucked this dude up with one punch and
he wants it back up and this.
And this guy goes,
you want to Luke kick?
You want to luke kick here right here.
You want to kick them out?
This.
He's like,
I'm going to try.
Takes a drag of a cigarette first and
then takes his shirt off.
Guy has no idea how to fight,
which is hilarious.
Fat,
not in shape kick guys.
But people are so ridiculous with this
idea that they think they know how to
fight.
Yeah,
Bang out cold.
But that's dark man.
The banging the head,
the back of the head off the concrete is
dark.
Yeah,
that's.
Memory's gone that fast.
It's a lot.
A lot gone.
A lot gone with your head.
That's why I used to always getting mad
at those movies where people get pistol
whipped and nothing would happen to wake
up.
Somebody who liked you had pistol whip
you because they needed to shut your
mouth.
You could fucking die or like they're
trying to get information out of them.
Like where's the money hidden?
It's like,
well now I don't remember.
And then when they would wake up they'd
have no problem.
So just be fighting.
No problems,
no coordination issues.
Meanwhile your equilibrium would be so
fucked.
Your legs wouldn't work.
Right.
Have you ever been knocked out like
other than that?
Not really,
no.
I've been in a lot of fights,
but I've never been knocked out.
Only that wrestling match a did it.
When you find out how vulnerable you
are,
like the human brain,
the way it's positioned in the head that
all has to do is get hit and yanked
around.
Okay.
Pretty deep.
I think I have a pro.
Well,
I think I have what they would call a
good chin.
He thinks so I've taken some fucking.
I've taken some real pain and but at
least when I was younger,
it's been a long time actually.
I took a good fucking solid head,
but about 10 years ago from my,
from one of my drunk comedian buddies.
Oh God,
yeah,
there's a great video of this girl had
buttons go unconscious outside of a bar.
You probably won't be able to find it,
but some,
some guys fucking with her and she's not
big.
She's pretty small and she grabs this
guy by the collar and just playing and
the dude just crumbles and drops to the
ground to fucking awesome.
So it's a real movement.
This part right here,
this is where people break their hands.
They break their hands on the top of the
forehead all the time.
It's not super hard spot and if you
smash someone on the jaw with that are
on the move that it chick actually can
pull off.
If she really knows how to do it,
grab someone's shirt and bang.
Yeah.
Hell yeah.
I've had a buddy people have you?
Yeah.
I've never had anybody in my life I've
been.
I've had to because you know,
I mean where I grew up,
it was just fights,
fights,
fights.
That was just the whole thing.
Youngstown,
Ohio.
Damn right.
Everybody was a boxer.
That's why all the boxers with me with
when Kelly.
Patty showed up.
Yeah,
it was awesome.
Right.
We all went out to dinner.
Yeah.
Matt Brown to a bunch of Ohio is hanging
out with Kelly pablet dude for someone
from youngstown.
That's as cool as it gets.
I've hung out with.
Boom.
I had to knock out Kelly for the
trifecta and that was amazing.
We had a.
We had a spread the size of this table.
I wasn't just any meal.
That was everything.
What do you want?
Because everything's on the table right
now.
Yeah.
We ate a lot of good food.
That was fun.
That was after the shot and steam.
Right.
Wow.
Schottenstein Center it,
right.
Schottenstein.
Yeah.
That was fun,
man.
That was a fun call.
Yeah.
Only show I've ever worn a football
jersey.
That was.
That was so cool.
I fucking Love Ohio.
I love Columbus.
Columbus is the Anti Connecticut.
Absolutely.
One hundred percent fun.
They're mad,
the opposite of Connecticut.
It's,
I mean,
people from Connecticut,
like,
what would I move to Columbus?
Just trust me.
Like if I would've done that same show
that I did in Connecticut in Columbus,
and there was an angry,
a lady that looked that angry in the
audience one face looking at me and I
said,
what are you so angry about?
She would answer the question.
Yeah,
yeah.
She would tell you,
yeah,
you shouldn't have said that about the
meeting.
And then at least I'd be able to really
go back and forth than I'd win winter
over.
But in Connecticut they just stay
staunch.
Oh,
that's young.
Jamie's photograph.
Yeah.
Young Jamie.
Photographer.
Extraordinary
number 18 for the Ohio state buckeyes.
We.
So,
uh,
what's going on with young Tony
Hinchcliffe career?
What's the latest?
I know you've been killing it with kill
Tony.
Tony is on a whole nother level.
We're having a lot of fun.
It's a blast.
We're taking them all over the road.
The road shows are insane.
Toronto was insane.
Absolutely insane.
We just did two shows in one night in
San Francisco.
Killed Tony Mania.
Where'd you guys go?
Chaos.
COBB's Ah,
two shows in one night on a Friday night
and Saturday.
The shows at home are crazy.
We have Whitney Cummings on Monday.
We have this new cool thing called the
apollo 13,
which is a,
which is this group of black people that
come every Monday,
like really basically like if any open
miker ever does like to racist of a joke
or if it's on the line or whatever,
they're like the judges like I'll like
point to them and it's like,
ah,
it's hilarious.
So funny.
We call them the apollo 13 because I
said that.
They're like,
yeah,
it's like David,
I'm shirts made three of the members
right there.
But it's like,
hi,
you're always adding new elements and
always mixing it up.
But it is one of the best live podcast
format ever will because it's so crazy.
It's so chaotic and you're guaranteed to
either get good comedy or terrible
comedy,
which equals great comedy.
Yeah.
Just to show you a span this past
Monday,
we started the show off with a former
reality star that,
uh,
that was horrible,
right?
He wasn't funny.
He's been doing it 14 years,
but he doesn't put any work into it,
no work ethic,
you know what I mean?
So it's like we roasted him in the
crowd,
loves it because he's such an easily
hateable guy.
The last guy we pull out of the bucket
comes out of the audience area a with
wearing shorts and one of his legs is a,
is amputated.
He has uh,
he has like a prosthetic leg and he
talks about how he nearly died six
months ago in a motorcycle accident and
he's a huge kill Tony Fan and this is
his first time doing standup.
This will,
we find this out after he has a decent
set for a minute.
It's his first time ever doing stand up.
The show keeps him from being depressed
and all that,
you know what I mean?
Like so this wide span is what helps
make it refillable like what you were
saying and you know,
it's just so cool because we're
basically when it comes to that pc stuff
that we were talking about earlier,
like I don't know if there's many places
where the vent for that where,
where you can get a real barometer
because look,
we have the apollo 13,
which they're called the apollo 13
because it's like showtime at the
Apollo,
but there's 13 of them.
So I call them the apollo 13.
This group of black people.
So like for example,
a few weeks ago,
this one kid,
like it doesn't even seem like he's 21
closes on this horrible joke about Kanye
was somebody needs to throw Kanye up
banana or something like that in the way
it's the whole place is in chaos.
Groaning in the apollo 13 standing up
like ah ha.
And it's like know since it's such a
live show that's sort of like,
you know,
if you,
if you make a racist joke,
that's not funny,
you're going to die dude.
You know what I mean?
Like that's the worst type of,
you know,
so since there's a real live comedy
crowd,
you get a real good barometer for what's
going on and it makes it more exciting
and it's just so,
so fun what we're doing.
Keeping it refillable,
like what you said,
finding new ways to tweak it here and
there.
And you know,
every time I go
go,
I do it like once every six months or
something like that.
Yeah,
it's always a new element is always
something new.
Something.
And the fact that the background guys
like Jeremiah and all those guys like
change outfits all the time and it
constantly doing new things.
It's just so ridiculous show.
And that's the king.
[inaudible] is the fucking king.
Yup.
He is so good at that shit.
Oh my God.
What a smile.
But red band.
Look at him.
Feel sad,
so serious.
Stole Dog.
Fuck.
[inaudible] the king of that shit
though.
He really is.
He's so good at it.
He said,
you know,
if he did it,
he did this thing a couple of weeks ago
where he said to a guy like,
he's like,
I like how you don't try to do that
whole funny thing.
You know,
everybody else tries these punchlines,
these comedy things,
not you.
Different Path all together.
Like he's so great at that.
He just says it like,
it's like he's giving a big compliment.
The new thing.
What's the Hannah Gadsby Path?
Oh
yeah.
Of people are doing anti comedy.
Catch up,
Tony.
Yeah.
I guess I will fucking cis gendered
white male piece of Shit.
I'm the bad guy.
Yup.
But yeah,
just uh,
doing a lot of standup,
ramping up to hopefully make another
special soon and uh,
I feel good about things.
So we'll see happens.
Life is good.
I'm pumped.
Beautiful.
Yeah.
Good to hear.
It's gonna be.
It's gonna.
Be a naughty special when and if it
happens,
not going to be like Nanette.
You're going to be naughty.
Yeah.
Hm.
We're going to talk about some things.
Are you.
I'm planning on being naughty or he just
naughty all the time.
It's modern day naughtiness and late
night naughtiness built in the darkness.
You comedy stores.
Yeah.
Good time for comedy.
Like a lot of people are complaining
about comedy right now and they think is
somehow or another,
this is a bad time for comedy,
but ours should fear said it best.
He said,
you know what's good about comedy right
now?
Comedy is dangerous.
Yeah.
There's real consequences to saying
fucked up things.
I agree 100 percent and in it makes us.
Some comedians are leaning towards it,
right?
Like,
ah,
I want that one.
I don't want to talk about that.
I don't want to talk about that,
and they're.
They're losing the losing the fun
because all of a sudden I get up there.
You know what I mean?
You have the whole.
All of a sudden you're touching the
untouchable.
It's exactly right.
It's also there's fun in explaining
yourself this fun and navigating the
waters like this.
One of the things that I.
I made sure that I did.
I thought very thought out very
thoroughly when I did strange times that
my last special,
I wanted to make sure I really thought
out how I can pull these bits off and
how I can make them like you,
Doug Stan Hope said it best.
He said he looks at his material like a
defense attorney,
like as if he's defending his,
his material like that's a great way to
look at it.
I look at my material like I'm a hater.
Like if I was a hater,
how would I poke fun at that file is
someone who is looking to be offended,
how would I so get that out of the way.
Like there was some bits that I did in
the last one in triggered that I changed
a lot of what they were from the
beginning to when I put them on film
because of the way audience members were
reacting.
I was like,
well,
clearly I'm having a problem with this
where they're not I,
I'm not even getting to the switch.
I'm not getting to the misdirect because
they're upset before I get to the
misdirect.
I'm not.
It's in.
It'll be fine if they let me get to the
end,
but sometimes they would heckle or they
would get upset.
Like One lady at the comedy store,
I had explained to her twice.
I go,
listen,
I'm saying it like this because I'm
going to shit on myself afterwards.
This is what I'm saying.
And this is what it was a bit about.
You remember that bit I used to do
about,
um,
a women can do anything men can do or
that's not true because men can't do
everything.
Some men can do.
That's why we have the Olympics.
Like the idea that everybody can do
everything.
That's ridiculous.
I go because it was the woman who
guarded the White House.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I was like,
I can't guard the White House.
Do you know how I know?
Because I met Shaquille o'neal and his
Dick is where my faces and I had
explained to her like,
this is the,
see,
this is where I was going to go with it.
If the White House is experiencing a
Shaq attack,
I'm the last guy to save the earth.
Okay.
He's just too fucking big.
You know,
and I would explode,
I was trying to get to this,
but I was,
this lady was getting upset at me before
I was,
so I had to think,
I was like,
okay,
if this was a drunk dummy,
how do I keep the drunk dummy from
popping off before I get to the
misdirect?
Like,
so I had to restructure things and I had
to figure out a way to make it so that
it's clear and like you,
um,
you just have to,
you just have to navigate the waters
more carefully,
but you could still get just as much
juice out of it,
just as much comedy and just as much
shit that's forbidden.
Taboo topics.
It's just,
you have to be really clear.
You have to be real,
you have to have good writing.
That's what's great about doing the
clubs on the road before necessarily
doing,
you know,
bigger venues or whatever is because you
really can feel them,
you know,
you feel where those moments are
sometimes in a bigger venue,
uh,
you,
you sort of,
you just,
you're sort of taking a gamble.
You know what's going to.
We know what's going to get a laugh.
I'm not a laugh,
but you can't really feel.
They're like,
don't do it.
Develop material in a big club.
Right.
Well,
I'd like a 10,000
seat room.
You don't develop material at a like Air
Canada center,
the,
you know,
the Scotia Bank arena that we went to,
develop any material there.
You better have that shit solid.
Yeah.
You can't even have it memorized.
It has to be part of your flow.
You're better than anything.
You have to know it better than you know
anything.
But like,
what is it,
the funny bone in Columbus?
Yeah.
That place you develop material there.
Comedy Works,
Denver developed material there.
Develop material and clubs.
You have to have both.
I,
I firmly believe that those guys who
just do big places and they only play to
their audiences,
they're fucking themselves.
Totally.
It's like an athlete that doesn't
strength train or it's like,
you know,
someone who doesn't,
uh,
they,
they work out,
but they don't watch their diet.
It's like you got man,
you gotta if you want the best results,
you got to do the whole thing.
They're out of touch.
I mean,
you gotTa,
you gotTa do the whole thing.
They,
those people.
Let's just,
I mean,
I don't want to name any names,
but let's just say a guy that's super
duper famous goes to a theater,
you know,
one of those big legends.
What they don't do is they don't
experiment not being funny.
What they should do is they should hire,
have a secret five minute experimental
bit buried in their set.
That's purposely nothing funny about it.
And we're on it.
And when they hear those laughs,
that's when they'll realize like,
oh shit.
Oh Shit.
They're laughing no matter what because
I have them trained.
Is that true?
If it's their fans and their dumb comedy
fans,
I'll laugh at things that aren't funny,
but I think they're going to laugh
harder at things that aren't as good.
I think they're gonna want,
like I went to see a comic.
I'm not gonna name any names.
Me and Joey Diaz went to Sam,
uh,
because we were playing in the place the
next night.
Yeah.
And it was,
it was one of those situations where
someone was doing their material for
audience and you could tell they hadn't
been working out in the clubs.
You could just see it and the people
wanted to laugh.
They want it to laugh.
There were,
there were,
there were fans and they were with it.
That's the difference between that and
say a set at the store when it's 11:00
PM on a Tuesday night when they've
already seen you and Joey Diaz and Ari
and all these other killers like you
gotta be funny.
Actually.
Funny.
It doesn't matter if you're,
you know,
some fill in the name whatever fucking
superstar.
You have to actually be funny.
They give you a minute or two to get
settled in on stays the clap and they're
excited to see you come with the fucking
jokes.
Barely.
Did they give you a minute?
Really?
They started second.
They really do.
It's really truly 30 seconds.
Especially in the or it really is.
It really is a he,
it's so hard to recover from a spinout
so much easier to start strong and take
chances and fizzle out than it is to not
start off on the right foot and get them
going.
It's also because they're right on top,
be on the or they're right there and
then you could just high five them
and they know that at that point they
know what's going on.
They know you better get to it.
They've already seen six of their
favorite new comedians that they're
already waiting to google the lineup
after they go home,
like they're like,
oh my God,
this is crazy,
and they know what the blue light in the
corner means.
All of a sudden they're like,
oh,
this guy's got three more minutes.
You better fucking stick that landing
that they're not that dumb.
It takes what?
Seeing two or three comedians in the
original room,
which is only 45 minutes before your
train and you know everything that's
going,
woo.
Here comes the piano guy.
Oop,
there goes the light.
You see the guy walking.
Exactly,
exactly.
The weirdest places,
the belly room.
That's the weirdest rail.
I fucking love that room.
That room.
So weird.
The birthplace of kill Tony.
That's another thing that makes kill
Tony Bon is.
It's like it was totally just.
It was a belly room baby and now you see
this big man like having killed Tony
Mania.
I drove a van of 14 people up there,
saw a big giant picture up from
instagram.
It was one of the coolest things.
I can't remember who was talking to last
night.
I says,
yeah,
and I said it was the coolest 24 hours
of my life because I picked everybody up
at the comedy store.
I go be at the comedy store,
9:00
AM Friday morning.
I'm going to pick you up and I'm driving
everybody back that night.
And I literally did.
I went and rented this big cool bad ass
fucking luxury van.
So you did two shows in San Francisco
and then you drove back that night?
Hell yeah.
What time did you get home?
Uh,
I think it was a seven or eight.
Actually it was like 8:00
AM.
How'd you stay awake?
Um,
first of all,
after a kill.
Tony,
I'm a freak for like three or four
hours,
so I knew that,
so I'm like,
that's going to be easy.
And I was like adrenaline,
like hosting adrenaline,
like I'm crazy about that show.
So it's like,
so much like I'm growing.
I'm looking at what we're,
what we're red bands,
fingers are,
I'm trying to get the guests,
all the,
the,
the bay,
you know,
it's,
I'm thinking moves ahead the whole time.
I'm super wired so I knew I really just
needed to survive the last two hours and
it was awesome,
man.
Hot Coffee,
beef Jerky,
cold sugar free.
Red Bull is enough for me.
My body was like,
what the fuck are you doing?
When I got home,
did you do a set Saturday night
anywhere?
Damn motherfucking right.
Main Room Baby.
I slept from 11:00
AM to uh,
to say like 6:30.
It was so cool.
That's awesome.
But the really cool thing is cheesy as
this is gonna sound is like taking those
14 people all with different backstories
all from different years and different
amounts of appearances.
Sarah wine shank and Allie Makowski were
regulars over the different years,
at different times that all the fans
know from seeing them each 100 times on
100 different episodes and this guy and
this guy and this guy and this guy in
the band and everybody was just on fire.
We met some of the best and worst people
you can imagine in all of San Francisco
in the history of the 303 episodes of
this show.
There's only been one guy that ever
walked off the stage angrily that
couldn't handle the heat that happened
in San Francisco like two and a half
years ago.
The same guy we,
we didn't realize until he did it again
that it was the same guy.
They walked off.
I go,
you know,
the only other time that anyone's ever
walked off and killed Tony History was
here in San Francisco and the crowd goes
and like 10,
15,
20 people stand up and literally go.
That was the same guy.
That was the second guy.
God,
I mean the energy of the show and the
fans and everything.
Man.
It's so cool.
But yeah,
I can't remember what made me get on
this,
but I drove everybody there and back and
it made it like such,
like a.
I was like,
I was like the dad for a day,
you know what I mean?
Like I bought everybody in and out on
the way up there.
Like it was so cool.
Everybody's just so happy.
Strawberry shakes.
The van is hilarious.
That's the second row there.
So like,
uh,
it's me and Allie Makowski in the front
and this was John Reap in the back.
Oh,
that's William Montgomery.
And he's coming for everybody's jobs.
That's that guy.
That guy is a genius.
He's like,
Andy Kaufman meets a fucking Tennessee
trucker.
He's common forever.
Everybody's going to know who that guy
is.
Eventually.
He's been doing it 11 years out of
Memphis,
Tennessee.
And he just got here a few months ago
and he's just an Improv Guru.
Like he just goes like,
you can,
he bullshits you can ask him anything.
And he's literally got like that,
uh,
that comedy twitch muscle where he just
riffs and it's the dumbest in the most
glorious shit.
At the same time,
this is the second row,
so you're ahead in the front here.
Driving.
Well,
Watkins takes pictures.
You got to aphrodite taken a nap.
Look at that fro second row from the
back.
He built the house artists.
You Got Josh who decided to sit in the
middle.
The continuous grump.
He gets,
he gets motion sickness in the end.
He didn't sit next to a window for some
reason.
So that's a genuine frown on his face.
Mikey mckernan in the back left.
I mean all these people did amazing
things.
It was just so incredible.
George and Christian.
Sling and merge at the front.
Yes.
Love,
like grassroots created shows like that
where it just started out as nothing and
then it became what it is now.
I just,
I love shit like that.
I love when people have an idea and they
stick with it.
And when you get to start doing the
golden pony our again speaking of which,
uh,
probably uh,
probably actually a really soon.
I just gotta I just gotTa do it.
I have to,
um,
I have to figure out whether I want to
do it at the comedy store.
Not though.
Seems like,
I don't know why not.
You're really good with live audiences
like that off the cuff.
Why not have a show like that and do it
in the belly room.
Do It on an off night and the belly
room.
Yeah.
You did one Monday night.
You were doing Monday night.
Yeah.
Find another leg off time.
Ten PM.
Especially if you do it late night,
like some weird late night show.
Yeah,
I think
you're right.
Actually.
That might be the of.
I think I need to do it in front of a
live audience.
It's your forte.
Yeah.
I mean you're great at that kind of
stuff.
And to do it in a small intimate room
like the belly room and to build it back
up,
you can get a logo and a big sign behind
you.
The Golden Pony,
our maybe a gold suit.
Maybe you do every show with a gold suit
on.
I liked the way you're talking now.
I'm telling you right.
I can fulfill the prophecy,
the prophecy
with the mastermind.
Remember the mastermind?
No,
the guy that writes everything
and executes it.
You could do something like that.
Like have a cool backdrop.
You know,
like some sort of a simple portable
backdrop.
We'll get that.
Oh Elvis.
Hell,
come on.
$40 for the cutout.
Stand up like the suits.
Only $40.
What's it made at?
See if you can find one of them.
Suits.
Gold's law.
What does that word?
Lemay.
What does that word mean?
L A M,
e dot.
I've seen that word before and it's one
of those words I never bothered to look
up.
Lame.
Hold on.
What does it mean?
A Le May suit.
Just type in suit him.
Unable to walk normally.
No,
that's lane bro.
Oh,
fabric.
It's the type of fabric
there it is.
It's a law.
May is the type of fabric woven or knit
with thin ribbons of metallic fiber.
Oh yeah.
That's your shit.
A fucking gold
will may suit.
Dude.
That's what I'm going to get.
Hold on.
Type in gold.
Lamay suit.
Here we go.
Baby.
1,200
black jacket.
Let me see.
Suits,
now we need to get some custom made
shirt.
That's we need to do.
If I hired someone to build you a suit,
would you?
Yeah.
Wear the shit out of it.
Alright,
you kidding me?
Here's someone out that shit.
That's ridiculous.
That one's a little ridiculous,
isn't it?
I don't know.
Any old iron sequin suit.
I mean that's sequent silver in there.
That shit's going to get in your fucking
clothes and stuff.
It'll get in the washing machine.
It looks like a tiny suit.
I think you need to get someone to make
you one of them.
I think we need to hire.
What does it say?
It's a Ninja suit.
That's.
Yeah.
Oh,
those poor causeway people.
Oh Geez.
Yeah.
Um,
we need to get something to make you
want.
Yeah.
It needs to be tailored properly.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
It's got to fit you.
We need to get David August.
That's the,
the company that makes uh,
they make conor mcgregor suits.
They make my suits for the UFC.
Yeah.
I can't wear regular suits and that.
I'm not built like a normal person.
So look at that.
She's wearing one hot bitch.
Ooh,
Damn.
Yeah.
Okay.
So we're going to do that.
I'm going to hire a David August to make
you a gold lamay suit that fits you
perfectly.
Yes.
This will be the launch and you'll have
heard about it here.
Folks.
Launch of the Golden Pony.
Our
live from the comedy store.
Wednesday night's live from the comedy
store in their belly room.
Midnight.
No,
I don't want to file a suit.
He's been farting and taking pills.
It's probably pills in that pocket.
They'll kill you right now.
Elton John,
Billy,
Joel and Elton John.
Sting all together again.
All right.
Um,
yeah,
so we'll do it.
And Dude,
uh,
I gotta finish my fucking act so we can
get on the road again.
I'm excited.
What does it now?
It's October 31st.
Tomorrow's the first.
I'm gonna Start doing mushrooms
immediately and uh,
I'm looking at 35 minutes now.
Thirty five minutes of time it out.
30 five new minutes.
I can actually do 30.
I could do a 35 minute set.
I did a 35 minute set.
I'm looking at January,
January.
Started poking dates.
I will love it.
You're going to start booking in January
or booking for January?
Yeah,
so November.
Stay in La.
December stain La January.
Maybe we do like the comedy works in
Denver in the fucking dead of winter.
What?
I think I'm going to London for the
first time in the middle of February.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
You'll love it out there.
Yeah,
they're.
They're very polite.
Do you remember the first time that we
did Stockholm and you thought that you
weren't doing well because they're very
polite in between sets and I had to say
no,
no.
They listen.
They were laughing.
He like,
I felt like,
by the way,
I didn't believe you.
I had to ask everybody me
that like security like I was.
I could not,
I,
I took what you said like I believed
you,
but I didn't really believe you.
Like I thought you were just being.
I thought you were being nice.
Like it's like,
oh,
he's trying to give me a pep talk.
Like,
Oh,
you know,
I just know that I know shit.
I'd tell you dude,
you could do better.
I know,
but I know you wouldn't do that.
That's why it was crazy to me because
I'm like either the,
either the world is different over here
on the other side of the world or
they're fucking with me.
Two things to take into consideration.
One is their second language,
so it's basically,
it's a novelty.
They're going out to see comedy,
which is a novelty.
Um,
I'm sure there are Swedish Comedians,
but I'm sure the timing and the
language,
it's just very different going from a
Swedish style comedy to American style
comedy,
but they're just really polite.
So they would,
they would laugh and then they would
stop and they would listen and you'll
like,
it just felt like dead in between the
bits.
I'm like,
I'm telling you,
man,
you did great.
But then you saw it when they were doing
it for my set and you're like,
oh,
that's how they really are.
Go,
yeah,
I go,
but they had a great time.
But they,
they laugh,
but they don't.
There's not like all this chatter
inbetween the joke,
right?
They wait and then they laugh and again
they laughed again.
But then your second set,
we did two shows that night.
You came out.
You were comfortable.
Yeah,
you're fine.
Because I embraced it.
I just stayed in the pocket instead of
being like,
what's going on?
Well,
they are that way in England as well in
England.
They really appreciate the craft.
They really appreciate standup comedy
and they really,
really appreciate it as a show.
They're extremely polite when they watch
shows.
I really enjoy performing there.
I like it a lot.
I haven't been there in awhile and I
know I should go back and I will,
I promise.
But um,
the last time I was in I was like,
man,
they're just,
they're intelligent,
they're polite,
like the way their watch a show,
like they go to see a show,
you know,
so that places great.
Manchester's great.
London's Great.
Um,
new castle did.
I did a lot of places in England at a
good time.
You know,
what else is fucking great,
but in a different way while doubling.
You got to do Dublin Dublin's chaos.
Yeah.
I want to go over there.
She got to get drunk.
Have they done a UFC there?
Yeah,
it was done.
You know,
Caesar?
Sure.
Yeah.
And Connor fought there,
I'm sure.
Uh,
um,
I don't know if there's been a ufc in
Dublin while he was huge though.
I don't know.
That's a good question because they were
going to do like a soccer stadium over
there.
What was the last time connor fought in
Dublin?
I don't know,
man.
It seems like that would make sense.
Yeah,
it was a cage wars fight.
One UFC,
UFC fight against Brandao.
Oh,
Diego Brandao second fight.
Just technically.
Yeah.
So I think is.
Yeah,
it's the first one was in Stockholm.
Then Boston and Dublin.
And then really what makes sense except
for.
Yeah,
now though,
Jesus Christ,
that God can't even walk in Dublin.
Okay.
I can't go anywhere.
Ooh,
that's something that we're about to do
together.
We're going to go to Toronto.
Oh yeah.
Girls fighting my girls.
Spiky guests.
Who's undefeated with me next to the
octagon?
You'll want to inject you damn right.
Guess who's about to be member when she
got that strawweight championship?
What'd she do?
She ran out of the octagon,
came and took a picture with Tony issue.
That's right.
Yes.
Yeah.
She reached into your pants and grabbed
your Melaleuca stick.
Yeah,
and I believe that's what's going to
happen again.
No,
she didn't do any of those things folks.
We're just joking.
Yeah,
we're kidding.
But she did jump out of the octagon and
take a picture with.
Well,
no,
that's a different one.
Yeah.
Punch you in the face and you're doing
nothing
that.
That was that one bottom right there
again and again and again and again.
Bottom right.
Yep.
Oh yeah.
She ran right out.
She came out and she pointed at me.
Yeah.
I'm going goes,
come over here.
Look at that with a belt on.
Yup.
That is hilarious.
Yeah,
it's a tough fight,
man.
She's fighting volunteership Chenko.
Valentina is a fucking murderer,
is a monster.
However,
I think not having to cut that extra 10
pounds is going to give you on a lot of
pop and a lot of extra energy and we're
going to see the old deal on a.
You know what I mean?
Rose had her number technically,
and.
But that's the only person we've ever
seen have her number.
So she,
she absolutely struggles to make,
make
115 pounds.
Absolutely.
Undeniably she,
she's an agonizing weight cut for her.
I think it'd be better for.
They have fought before they fought two
or three times in Moitai.
And Valentine is one.
All the fights.
Yeah.
Valentina is a beast man.
And she's bigger.
Valentina is coming down from 35 to
1:25,
but I like it a lot.
It's probably one of the more technical
female mma fights you're ever going to
see in terms of like,
you know,
you want to be in a world champion Moy
Thai fighter found Tina being at that
same level.
They're just both super,
super technical.
I'm pumped.
That's going to be fun.
We're going to hang out in Toronto.
Hell yeah.
All right.
Let's wrap this thing up.
So rocktober,
it's been a good time.
So over.
Let me see the standings.
See if anybody made a wild push today to
try to.
Is it,
does it end at midnight east coast or
west coast?
You guys have.
Have you said that east coast,
because six hours going on with my
fucking phone six and a half ago.
It won't let me open the phone.
Oh,
great.
New Bug.
Apple stuck in another location and
notifications stuck in.
It hasn't even shown up.
Look at that.
Wonderful.
Close it.
And then try to get wonderful new bug.
Yeah,
but what's up with that bug?
That's fucking terrible.
Oh,
it's doing it again at a button.
You can.
Wonderful.
Wonderful new bug.
That's crazy.
You
fucking piece of shit.
Goodnight everybody.
Better fucking stupid.